madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mes chers collègues
avant d'appeler l'ordre du jour je
voudrais saluer le secrétaire général de
l'Assemblée nationale et de la
présidence Monsieur Michel Moreau qui
est assis derrière moi
[Applaudissements]
il participe aujourd'hui à sa dernière
séance de questions au gouvernement
c'est une vie au service de l'Assemblée
nationale
il y est entré en 1981
on a gravit tous les échelons jusqu'à
atteindre le plus élevé d'entre eux en
2016 il a servi notre institution avec
l'exigence et le professionnalisme qui
font honneur à la fonction publique
parlementaire je tiens à l'assurer en
votre nom à tous de la reconnaissance
sincère de l'Assemblée nationale merci
je vous remercie
et donc l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au Gouvernement
la première d'entre elles va être posée
par Monsieur Jordan Guitton pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'économie et des finances alors qu'un
Français sur trois ne partira pas en
vacances cet été alors que la période
estivale est déjà impactée par une
inflation globale alors que certaines
urgences seront fermées ou réguler comme
dans mon département de l'Aube alors que
la France connaît la plus haute
augmentation de faillite d'entreprises
de son histoire après de 50% sur un an
alors qu'en février les factures
d'électricité ont déjà augmenté de 15%.
nous apprenons aujourd'hui une nouvelle
hausse de 10% du prix de l'électricité
concrètement depuis deux ans la hausse
réelle des prix de l'électricité est de
31% et de plus de plus 26% rien que sur
les six derniers mois où est votre
parole monsieur le ministre lorsque vous
annonciez qu'il n'y aurait pas de
rattrapage sur les prix de l'électricité
en 2023 vous avez par votre mensonge
alimenter la défiance de nos
compatriotes envers la parole publique
quand allez-vous reprendre le contrôle
sur les prix de l'électricité et enfin
appliquer les mesures de bon sens
portées par Marine Le Pen en revenant au
tarif réglementés en désindexant le prix
de l'électricité sur celui du gaz en
abaissant le taux de TVA de 20 à 5,5 sur
toutes les énergies dont l'électricité
en soutenant une politique ambitieuse
sur le nucléaire en sortant des règles
du marché européen de l'électricité vos
promesses de réforme ont d'ailleurs
lamentablement échoué devant le refus
allemand avec ces mesures nous serions
attractif pour l'économie pour nos
entreprises et pour le pouvoir d'achat
des Français avec vous c'est la double
peine pour les Français il paye toujours
plus de taxes et une électricité
toujours plus chère où passe leur argent
alors ma question est simple monsieur le
ministre allez vous agir où allez-vous
partir
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Agnès panière une ministre de la
transition énergétique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Guiton même si cela vous déplaît de le
reconnaître la France et le pays qui a
le plus protégé ses concitoyens face à
l'augmentation des prix de l'énergie ces
deux dernières années c'est ce
gouvernement et cette majorité qui ont
agi fortement dès le début de la crise
énergétique pour protéger les Français
les collectivités locales et les
entreprises face aux prises électricité
boucliers tarifaires amortisseurs
électricité filet de sécurité chaque
énergie ont été autant de dispositifs
mises en place ont un temps record ces
deux dernières années cet effort c'est
40 milliards d'euros rien que pour le
bouclier électricité sur la période 2022
2023 c'était fort massif c'est un choix
assumé pour protéger un choix assumé
pour que les français bénéficient des
prix d'électricité parmi les plus bas
d'Europe la majorité présidentielle
peut-être fier d'avoir mis tout ce qui
était en saut pour voir pour protéger
les Français
l'irresponsabilité monsieur le député
Guiton elle est du côté de ceux qui ont
refusé de voter ces dispositifs elle est
du côté du rassemblement national car
comme à son habitude vous parlez
beaucoup mais vous faites peu au
contraire nous avons pris nos
responsabilités si nous n'avions pas
agile les factures des Français auraient
doublé en février et vous le savez selon
la Commission de régulation de l'énergie
il est tarifs d'électricité aurait été
augmenté de près de 75% le gouvernement
n'a pas suivi ce calcul et à opter pour
une autre limitée de 10%. aussi nous
serons extrêmement vigilants avec le
ministre de l'économie et des finances
Monsieur le Maire le maintien du
bouclier tarifaire permettra de prendre
en charge plus du tiers je le répète
plus du tiers de la facture des Français
c'est massif monsieur le député
je vous remercie madame la ministre
monsieur Guiton merci madame la ministre
par votre éponge vous avez trahi les
entreprises et les artisans par vos
choix économiques vous avez trahi nos
fleurons par électoralisme vous avez
trahi les Français par la parole un jour
ou l'autre il vous balayeront par les
urnes
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Loïc hervant
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
si vous le permettez je souhaiterais
commencer cette intervention en rendant
hommage à Manon Labarre je ne
sapeur-pompiers de ma circonscription
décédé en intervention samedi
merci pour elle je veux redire à sa
famille ses proches ses camarades du
centre de secours de Culan à quel point
la nation est triste mais aussi fier de
son engagement et des valeurs qu'elle
portait ma question s'adresse à monsieur
le garde des sceaux il y a maintenant un
peu plus d'une semaine les Françaises et
les Français ont été les témoins de
scènes d'une violence inouïe 12000
voitures brûlées 105 incendies et
dégradation de mairie 68 attaques
d'école 17 atteintes aux élus la lecture
de ces chiffres témoigne de la gravité
des exactions commises alors que nous
allons discuter cette semaine dans ces
murs d'une loi mettant les moyens pour
réparer les conséquences de ces
violences j'aimerais que vous nous
rassuriez sur les fêtes que ces actes ne
resteront pas impunis je vous parle
depuis des territoires ruraux comme le
mien qui n'ont pas participé à ses
émeutes mais aussi depuis les zones
touchées ou beaucoup ont des approuvé et
vu avec effarmant ce déchaînement la
réponse des forces de sécurité sur
l'instant a été à la hauteur et je
remercie encore une fois nos forces de
l'ordre il ne doit pas subsister de
doute sur la réponse pénale notre pays
pas besoin que la loi s'applique dans sa
fermeté à tous je sais monsieur le garde
des sceaux votre engagement la
circulaire adressée au procureur il y a
quelques jours appelé à une réponse
ferme systématique et rapide vous avez
aussi fait entrer en vigueur le code de
la justice pénale des mineurs qui
réforme totalement le traitement
judiciaire des affaires impliquant des
mineurs délinquants ou criminels
pouvez-vous nous dire en quoi cette
nouvelle procédure va permettre de
répondre efficacement au profil de ces
émeutiers parfois très jeunes de manière
plus générale sur les réquisitions et
les peines prononcées ou en sommes-nous
aujourd'hui pourriez-vous monsieur le
ministre détaillez la réponse pénale que
les tribunaux ont apporté au récentes
émeutes je vous remercie merci beaucoup
de la justice
merci Madame la
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
qui avons permet des mois d'abord de
m'associer au vibrant hommage que vous
avez rendu
à la jeune Manon sapeur-pompiers
volontaire de votre département son
engagement et celui de tous ceux qui
protègent la République
nous oblige tous
dans ma circulaire
dans ma circulaire du 30 juin 2023 sur
les violences urbaines et dans la
Dépêche relative au festivités du 14
juillet j'ai demandé et je demande
encore ici devant la représentation
nationale que les procureurs de notre
pays totalement mobilisés et auquel je
veux ici solennellement rendre hommage
apporte une réponse pénale ferme rapide
systématique c'est le triptyque qui
définit ma politique pénale de fermeté
sans aucune démagogie j'ai aussi rappelé
avec force que les personnes qui
appellent à la violence et à la haine
via les réseaux sociaux ne sauraient se
retrancher derrière l'anonymat il y a
pas de zone de l'endroit vous le savez
de nombreuses poursuites ont été
engagées et plus d'une dizaine de
premières condamnations et d'Ores
étaient là tomber après plus de 15 jours
le bilan de cette circulaire est à la
hauteur les chiffres par le domaine
entre le 27 juin et le 13 juillet
1278 jugements ont été prononcés avec
95% de condamnation et souvent avec
mandat de dépôt plus de 1300 déferments
du parquet 905 personnes ont fait
l'objet d'une comparution immédiate 1056
personnes ont été condamnées à une peine
d'emprisonnement 90% des condamnés dont
742 à une peine d'emprisonnement ferme
62%. le quantum moyen ferme s'élève à
8,2 mois près de 600 personnes ont été
incarcérées 608 mineurs ont été déférés
la justice a répondu présent pour faire
revenir l'ordre républicain aux côtés
des policiers des gendarmes mais après
30 ans d'abandon elle a besoin que vous
répondiez présents tous les républicains
sur ces bancs de gauche à droite en
votant dans quelques heures là aussi
storique de plus de 7,5 milliards
d'euros du budget de la justice merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Rault pour le groupe écologiste
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre nous sommes le 18 juillet la
canicule à câble une partie de l'Europe
avec une vague de chaleur qui fait
exploser le thermomètre au-delà des 40
degrés malgré le deuxième mois de juin
le plus chaud dans notre pays le déni
climatique du gouvernement ne rougit pas
le ministre de l'Agriculture considère
que ces températures n'ont rien
d'extrême mais sont plutôt normal pour
un été non monsieur le ministre rien
n'est normal dans ce que nous vivons
notre maison brûle et 21 ans après la
formule célèbre du président Chirac nous
regardons toujours ailleurs car en
France il est évident que nous n'avons
plutôt que vous n'avez toujours pas pris
la mesure du combat à livrer nous sommes
le 18 juillet toujours pas de conseils
de planification écologique de nouveau
reporter le réchauffement climatique lui
ne recule pas ce n'est pas la priorité
du président Macron un président qui
élève au rang d'Officier de la Légion
d'honneur le PDG de Total énergie
compagnie dont les projets écossiles se
poursuivent au même rythme que les
profits indécents hier la Cour des
comptes publiait un rapport sévère sur
l'absence de planification
opérationnelle pour faire face à la
dramatique raréfaction de la ressource
en eau pourtant des plans il y en a et
certains pays ont déjà pris la mesure de
l'ampleur des décisions à prendre par
exemple le Pays de Galles annule ces
projets routiers car impossible
d'atteindre le 0 carbone à moins
d'arrêter de faire la même chose encore
et encore ici cette semaine on essaie de
nous sur une nouvelle fable celle de
l'industrie verte qui au lieu de
remettre en cause le modèle d'une
production sans limite prétend résoudre
par magie nos problèmes de décarbonation
monsieur le ministre nous attendons pas
de la part de votre gouvernement des
lendemains qui chantent mais pour éviter
des lendemains qui brûlent et qui
épuisent les ressources quant allez-vous
enfin prendre vos responsabilités et
agir à la hauteur de l'immense défi qui
nous fait face la pensée magique
n'existe pas quand allez-vous enfin
sortir du déni
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
députéro
quand allez-vous enfin sortir des
discours et des mots tout fait quand
allez-vous regarder y compris le dernier
rapport du Conseil pour le climat et les
propos de la présidente Corinne Le Quéré
qui rappelle qu'il y a à l'heure
actuelle 18 pays sur la planète qui
depuis plus de 10 ans baisse tous les
ans leurs émissions de gaz à effet de
serre quant allez vous regarder les
chiffres du cité pas qui montrent que la
baisse pour l'année 2022 a été de 2,7%
en termes de baisse des gaz à effet de
serre la vérité monsieur RAW c'est que
oui nous devons accélérer nous devons
doubler le rythme de notre baisse la
vérité qui dit qu'il faut on doit agir
sur tous les fronts sur l'adaptation
parce qu'il y a aujourd'hui un
réchauffement climatique qui est déjà
irréversible sur l'atténuation à la fois
en France et en mobilisant la diplomatie
environnementale pour avoir d'autres
acteurs qui se mobilisent à nos côtés
nous devons agir avec la planification
écologique quand on tient des conseils
vous ne dites que c'est pas assez
ambitieux quand ils n'ont pas lieu vous
nous expliquerez qu'il faudra les réunir
la vérité monsieur RAW c'est que si les
écologistes arrêtaient de penser que
l'avenir de leur planète et leur
fonde-commerce on aurait plus de chance
de s'en sortir alors je vous invite à
sortir des postures je vous invite à
regarder en face la réalité je vous
invite à nous soutenir quand ça va dans
le bon sens je vous invite à saluer les
7 milliards de rois non c'est par la
première ministre je vous invite à
saluer les efforts de formation qui ont
été lancés je vous invite à soutenir le
plan d'adaptation je vous invite à
soutenir le plan haut au motif que ce
n'est pas vous qui présentez vous faites
comme si ça n'était rien les Français ne
sont pas dupe sinon vous seriez dans une
autre situation
je vous remercie
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Amar
pour le groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre l'Europe est frappée
par une chaleur intense qui s'étend
désormais sur toute la France et le
bassin méditerranéen dans ce contexte
compliqué pour nos concitoyens les
propos de votre Ministre de
l'Agriculture samedi sont France Inter
ne sont pas acceptables non nous ne
connaissons pas des températures
normales pour un été 68% des nappes
phréatiques sont à des niveaux sous les
normales de saison et ne sont pas
rechargés depuis l'été dernier le mois
de juin était le mois le plus chaud
après celui de 2003 les Français
souffrent au travail et chez eux dans 25
millions de bâtiments bouilloire
thermique pendant que des ultras riches
que vous récompensez par des légions
d'honneur comme Monsieur pouyanet PDG de
Total énergie poursuivre poursuivre avec
gourmandise depuis des salons climatisés
leur sport préféré
détruire la planète
quand il fait pour mériter les honneurs
de la nation sûrement pas d'avoir agi
pour que les 330 000 sans-abris et les 4
millions de mal logés supportent la
vague de chaleur qu'en est-il pour nos
concitoyens de Mayotte qui doivent faire
face depuis hier à des coupures de au
quotidiennes ce matin je vous adressé
une lettre pour vous demander au titre
de l'article 50-1 de notre constitution
de déclencher un débat en hémicycle pour
un plan d'urgence au pour Mayotte
ma question madame la Première ministre
au lieu de décorer le roi du pétrole
quand est-ce que vous agirez
concrètement au service de la planète
indispensable à nos concitoyens et nos
concitoyens et aux vivants
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Amar
je suis heureux de vous entendre parler
du climat parce que les seules
températures qui vous intéressait
jusqu'à maintenant c'était celle des
émeutes urbaines
depuis des semaines
quand ce gouvernement a présenté le 20
juin dernier son plan de gestion des
vagues de chaleur où étiez-vous où
étiez-vous début du mois de juillet
quand on parlait de l'eau vous souffliez
sur les braises des émeutes dans les
banlieues
la seule température qui vous
intéressait c'était celle là alors venir
ici prendre un micro et faire en sorte
d'essayer de faire une polémique sans
vous parce que votre seul objet ça n'est
pas de parler des vagues de chaleur
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une parmi les finances la vérité et les
vols tu verras rien vous essayez de
faire mes chers collègues un peu de
calme
les Français ce week-end vous savez ce
qui les a sidéré c'est pas la liste
c'est pas la liste des premiers à la
Légion d'Honneur ce sont les propos
indignes de Jean-Luc Mélenchon sur le
CRIF c'est les accusations
d'antisémitisme et aujourd'hui que vous
veniez ici pour tenter de faire
diversion ça ne trompe personne les
Français sont pas dupe vous voulez
débattre du fond faisons-le la
planification écologique c'est nous les
budgets c'est nous le plan s'il vous
plaît l'adaptation un peu de silence il
vous reste plus trans
il vous reste les fake news à la madame
Rousseau sur les 60 degrés et il vous
reste pour le reste le fait de confondre
l'écologie politique avec la sauvegarde
de la planète
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre un
peu de silence s'il vous plaît
monsieur
[Musique]
provocation ni changeront rien monsieur
le ministre ça prouve que vous êtes en
manque d'inspiration alors je vous
invite à télécharger notre plan haut sur
notre site internet
je vous remercie
la parole
la parole était un peu de silence s'il
vous plaît
la parole est la parole est à Monsieur
Philippe la tombe pour le groupe
démocrate merci madame la présidente
madame la Présidente s'il vous plaît
merci
ma question c'est pas la parole vous
n'avez pas la parole
Monsieur latombe Merci ma question
s'adresse à Madame la Ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères dans
une réaction commune sans précédent la
quasi-totalité des partis politiques et
groupe parlementaires des parlements
français et européens ce sont tous
retrouvés pour contester la nomination
par la Commission européenne de Fiona
Scott Morton comme chef économiste à la
direction générale de la concurrence
en aucun cas une remise en cause du
brillant parcours universitaire de cette
professeur de Yelle mais celle de son
activité de lobbyiste pour Amazon Apple
ou Microsoft entre autres et de son
tropisme avéré en faveur des grandes
sociétés nous n'avons pas là le profil
d'une future fonctionnaire au service de
l'Union européenne mais bien plutôt d'un
conflit d'intérêt latent cette
nomination intervient dans un contexte
d'adaptation par le Parlement de notre
droit national des digital marketact et
digital service Isaac dérèglement
européens qui prévoient de limiter la
domination économique des grandes
plateformes et la diffusion en ligne de
contenu et de produits illicite parler
d'un fâcheux hasard tient de
l'euphémisme
couvrons ce conflit d'intérêt que nous
ne saurions voir semble dire la
commission qui pour sauver sa décision
propose que la nouvelle chef économiste
se met en retrait de sa mission chaque
fois qu'un conflit intéresse annoncera
la majeure partie des sujets qui seront
à traiter concerne les gafam on peut
ainsi s'interroger sur la crédibilité
d'un tel choix sur l'intérêt de placer
un tel fonction une personne qui ne
pourra de toute façon que très
partiellement l'exercer madame la
ministre le groupe démocrate ne comprend
pas cette nomination l'Europe n'a-t-elle
pas la capacité à trouver en son sein
parmi 447 millions de personnes une
compétence digne de ce poste ainsi nous
souhaitons savoir comment vous envisagez
madame la ministre de convaincre la
Commission européenne de revenir sur
cette décision je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier bèche
ministre chargé du Commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité des Français de
l'étranger merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur les députés Philippe
lattes je vous prie d'abord de bien
vouloir excuser l'absence de la ministre
de l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
qui est sur le chemin du retour du
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies à
New York sans se prononcer sur les
qualités professionnelles de Madame
Fiona Scott Morton qui est nationalité
américaine cette nomination au poste
d'économiste en chef de la direction
générale de la concurrence à la
Commission européenne suscite de
nombreux interrogations légitimes par la
voie de la ministre coloniale de
Laurence Boone et de Jean-Noël Barrault
ce gouvernement a rapidement réagi et
nous l'avons fait de manière publique
car ce sujet d'intérêt collectif c'est
également votre cas d'ailleurs monsieur
le député comme le montre votre question
il faut aussi relever de nombreuses voix
qui se sont élevées au Parlement
européen notamment les présidents de
groupe qui ont écrit à la Commission
européenne des la semaine dernière
aux substances cette nomination fait
peser un risque sérieux de conflits
d'intérêt alors que la régulation
numérique fait figure de priorité pour
l'Union européenne il est difficilement
justifiable de nommer quelqu'un dont les
activités professionnelles antérieures
consistait à promouvoir précisément les
intérêts des grandes entreprises
directement concernées et s'il y a un
système de déport été mis en place cela
consisterait en fait à vider le poste de
l'essentiel de sa substance vous avez
parfaitement raison de plus cette
nomination soulève une question
politique en réalité aucun pays ne
confierait de telles responsabilités un
ressortissant étranger c'est une
question évidente de souveraineté
européenne nous attendons donc de la
commission qu'elle réexamine cette
domination et nous nous l'avons dit très
précisément l'objectif n'est nullement
de s'immiscer dans le pouvoir de
nomination de la commission qui lui
appartient mais nous attendons de cette
dernière qu'elle fasse preuve de tout le
discernement et de toute la rigueur
nécessaire dans la nomination à des
postes aussi stratégiques et la ministre
Catherine Colonna abordera ce sujet lors
du conseil des ministres à faire
étrangères de jeudi cette semaine merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur meilleur ami pour
le groupe les républicains
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre de la Culture
levez-vous monsieur Hitler il y a des
personnes qui ont besoin d'être brûlées
il incombe à chaque palestinien de tuer
un juif et la faire éclose non ce ne
sont pas les propos d'un djihadiste il
souhaite à mourir terroriste dulp reçu
en héros bien national par l'extrême
gauche et qui donne des conférences dans
nos prisons avec l'accord de la
Chancelerie monsieur le garde défauts ce
sont des tweets de journalistes de la
chaîne arabophone de France 24 appelant
à la haine des Juifs trois des quatre
journalistes mis en cause sont toujours
en poste et rémunérés par les impôts des
Français aucune réaction de votre part
face à ses propos néo-nazis vous qui
vous alarmez le dimanche matin pour nos
valeurs républicaines quand Jean froid
le jeune jugeait d'extrême droite et
nommé à la tête du JDD la vérité cruelle
le plus réalisme des médias comme pour
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
vous terrorise vous votre pièce sipron
pas qualifier Bolloré Europe 1 sinus
d'ennemis de notre démocratie pour vous
tout ce qui est à droite patriote ou un
transigeant avec les migration et
l'insécurité est taxé d'extrême droite
en revanche
vous gardez le silence sur
l'antisémitisme niché durablement au
cœur du service public notre démocratie
mérite mieux que le Reducto a hitlero
une théorisé après guerre par les
staliniens et repris ce dimanche par
Mélenchon et ses propos mensongers et
scandaleux sur le président du CRIF le
jour de la commémoration du Vél d'Hiv la
bête immonde a de vrais fantassins dans
l'espace politique et médiatique mais
vous vous trompez de tanière votre
croisade moraliste masque mal votre
complaisance vis-à-vis nouvelle
antisémitisme qui a diabolisation
d'Israël si présente dans le service
public et qui tue en France de Toulouse
à sarahimie rappelez-vous les mensonges
et les terribles conséquences de
l'affaire aldura Madame le Ministre
pourquoi cette intellectuelle n'oubliez
pas jamais que votre ministère est celui
de Malraux cette immense combattant de
l'eau contre l'antisémitisme mais
dites-vous le même zèle que celui des
foyers contre Vincent Bolloré à moins
pour vous un milliardaire catholique
breton soit plus dangereux pour la
démocratie que les islamistes et les
antisémites
la parole est à madame Isabelle Rome
ministre chargé de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes de la diversité et
de l'égalité des chances
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît madame
la Présidente c'est madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Député meilleur Habib je
reviens sur les attaques du leader de la
France insoumise contre le président du
Nathan
13150 de Juifs
c'est indignes
pour ces femmes
ces hommes ces enfants un peu de tenue
j'étais dimanche à la maison des yeux en
souvenir des victimes des crimes
racistes et antisémites de l'État
français pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et pour rendre hommage au juste
de France et je retiens à redire ici
tout mon soutien il y en a tant Arfi
avec lequel nous avons élaboré avec
d'autres associations le plan du
gouvernement contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme lancé par la première
ministre désormais chaque enfant
effectuera au cours de sa scolarité une
visite d'un lieu mémorielle non on n'est
plus le même quand on a vu de Rancy
quand on a vu à Auschwitz ou la maison
des enfants des yeux et on comprend ce
qu'elle antisémitisme cette idéologie
qui a conduit à la mort des millions de
personnes et on comprend pourquoi il est
indigne de faire de la petite politique
avec les pierres CRIM de l'histoire oui
car l'antisémitisme n'est pas mort il
continue de faire des victimes en France
le gouvernement ne laissera rien passer
nous lutterons toujours sans relâche
contre le racisme
l'antisémitisme et la haine de l'autre
et j'invite s'il vous plaît insoumise et
son leader à un sursaut de dignité à
nous rejoindre dans ce combat non pas
seulement pour les Français juifs non
pas seulement pour la France mais pour
une certaine idée de l'humanité
je vous remercie madame la ministre
merci beaucoup
s'il vous plaît un peu de silence
[Applaudissements]
merci d'écouter les réponses qui vous
sont faites monsieur s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
vous choisissez vos questions le
gouvernement choisi ces réponses
Monsieur Olivier Faure pour le groupe
socialiste vous avez la parole
ma présidente
la première ministre nous avons cru
comprendre que vous aviez obtenu un
nouveau sursis en effet puisque tout va
si bien pourquoi changer de cap d'après
l'Élysée je cite l'objectif des 100
jours d'apaisement a été tenu à ce
niveau de déconnexion on reste sans voix
c'est 100 jours viennent après cinq mois
d'un mouvement social inédit son non
retraite vous êtes passé en force contre
l'immense majorité des Français
qu'avez-vous apaisé les Français
souffrent de l'inflation pourtant au
cœur des vacances le tarif de
l'électricité va compter de 10% après
une augmentation de 15% en février
qu'avez-vous apaisé vos propres experts
considèrent que la richesse insolente
des super riches devraient être
mobilisées pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique mais vous avez
refusé d'évoquer le retour de l'ISF
qu'avez-vous apaisé l'accès aux soins
est devenu chimérique en toute une
partie du territoire mais vous je vais
rejeter une proposition pourtant
transpartisane portée par Guillaume
Garraud sur les déserts médicaux
qu'avez-vous apaisé les journalistes du
Journal du dimanche sont en grève et
interpellent votre pouvoir pour qu'il
intervienne le seul ministre qui a eu le
courage d'affronter la main mise de
l'extrême droite sur ce journal n'a reçu
aucun soutien de votre part qu'avez-vous
apaisé des
uber fails au fond Schiappa plus une
semaine sans que soit évoqué les
relations troubles entre gouvernement
lobby et intérêt privé vous regardez
ailleurs qu'avez-vous apaisé suite à la
mort filmée de Naël nous venons de
connaître des violences urbaines d'une
intensité rare mais le président a
annoncé au maire de France qu'il ne
mettrait pas un centime de plus en au
quartier qu'avez-vous apaisé le
président du groupe LR au Sénat a évoqué
vous avez coulé votre temps la parole
est à Monsieur Olivier Véran
porte-parole du gouvernement et ministre
en charge du renouveau démocratique
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Olivier fort
il se trouve que j'ai l'immense honneur
de répondre au premier secrétaire d'un
parti que j'ai beaucoup aimé
un parti qui prenait le travail comme la
première des solidarités la sécurité
comme la première des libertés qui
prenait le renforcement des services
publics et qui promettaient aux Français
d'atteindre la transition énergétique
monsieur le député pendant votre
question j'ai regardé les votes qui ont
été les vôtres au cours de ces 100 jours
et au cours des cinq mois que les ans
précédaient puisque vous en parliez et
je me dis à regarder ces votes que vous
avez décidément beaucoup changé monsieur
le député figurez-vous pendant ces 100
jours nous avons fait adopter des lois
fondamentales pour les Français et loi
qui modernise nos armées une loi qui
modernise notre justice lui accorde des
moyens considérables comme elle en avait
jamais eu le Parti socialiste que j'ai
quitté à l'époque Monsieur les buté
aurait voté ce texte regardez-moi dans
les yeux et dites que je dis faux bien
sûr que non la transition énergétique et
la planification écologique qui va nous
permettre d'atteindre un objectif
inespéré sous le quinquennat Hollande et
vous et moi le savons parfaitement de
réduire de 50-5% les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est le planification
vous devriez l'embrasser au-delà des
désaccords formels au-delà des dés
politique au-delà des effets de tribune
au-delà des volontés électorales qui
sont votre droit parce que nous sommes
en démocratie je vous assure que vous
sortiriez grandis monsieur le député
d'une part à reconnaître quand vous êtes
profondément d'accord avec la politique
qui est conduite et peut-être ou dire
d'aller plus loin que ce que nous
faisons mais tout jeter comme vous le
faites n'est pas crédible et Monsieur le
Député pendant ces 100 jours
qu'avez-vous fait de votre côté
qu'avez-vous fait de vos partenaires qui
défilaient dans les manifestations
interdites qu'avez-vous fait de vos
partenaires qui criaient tout le monde
déteste la police qu'avez-vous fait de
vos partenaires qui n'arrivaient pas à
condamner les émeutes urbaines et les
violences mais c'est les buté vous les
concombres votre bilan et le nôtre le
nôtre il fait progresser la France
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est Madame Anne bruniera pour
le groupe Renaissance
merci Madame
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Justice en 2022 en France
3267 personnes ont trouvé la mort dans
un accident de la route et plus de 16000
ont été gravement blessés
92% des accidents mortels sont causés
par un facteur humain 30% par une
vitesse excessive 22% par la conduite
sous l'emprise de l'alcool 13% sur par
les stupéfiants nous ne pouvons nous
résoudre à ce triste bilan
l'accidentologie et la mortalité
routière doivent baisser les leviers
pour agir sont pluriel éducation
routière bien sûr vérification de
l'aptitude à la conduite amélioration
des infrastructures et bien évidemment
prévention et répression des
comportements de violences routières en
juin j'ai déposé avec 38 collègues une
proposition de loi visant à instaurer
une infraction spécifique distincte de
l'homicide involontaire l'omside routier
pour caractériser l'homicide causé par
le conducteur d'un véhicule dans
certaines substances vitesse excessive
conduite sous l'emprise d'alcool ou de
stupéfiants ou sans permis
usage du téléphone portable au volant
des circonstances telles que la mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui apparaît dès
lors comme délibéré dans de telles
circonstances la qualification domicile
involontaire est inadaptée elle est mal
vécue par les victimes et les familles
des victimes que nous comprenons la
création de l'homicide routier vise à
responsabiliser les auteurs à réaffirmer
la gravité de leur comportement elle
permettra une meilleure reconnaissance
du statut de victime il convient aussi
de parler des peines car au-delà des
peines encourues ce sont souvent les
peines prononcées exécutées beaucoup
plus clémente qui provoquent la colère
de celles et ceux mer perd enfant
fratrie qui ont perdu un être cher
fauché sur la route ou le trottoir à
l'issue du CISR hier madame la Première
ministre annoncé 38 mesures pour
améliorer la sécurité sur la route dont
la création de l'homicide routier dès
lors monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
nous indiquer quel serait les modalités
d'application de cette homicide en
termes de circonstances et de peine et
quelle traduction légis arrive
envisagez-vous sur ce sujet pour nous
députés mobiliser depuis longtemps sur
ce sujet dans mes collègues Eric Roger
et Pierre Morel à Lucie je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
Eric Dupont-Moretti garde des sceaux et
ministre de la Justice merci madame la
présidente madame messieurs les députés
madame la députée brudera d'abord je
veux vous remercier pour votre question
je soulignais votre engagement sur ce
sujet et je veux également vous
remercier pour votre proposition de loi
n'oublie pas non plus d'autres députés
qui sont mobilisés sur cette question je
pense en particulier à Monsieur Poget
mais également un monsieur Morel à lui
notre code pénal vous l'avez dit ne peut
pas engendrer une incompréhension et
rajouter de la souffrance chez les
victimes c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons appeler très justement cette
infraction l'homicide routier déjà il y
a une distinction entre l'homicide
involontaire j'allais dire classique
puni de trois ans d'emprisonnement
et l'homicide qui est perpétré au volant
d'un véhicule en cas d'excès de vitesse
en cas de prise de substance les
pénalités sont aujourd'hui selon les
circonstances aggrave entretenues 5 ans
7 ans ou 10 ans donc nous allons
effectivement mettre en place cette
infraction et nous allons surtout la
sortie des autres homicides
involontaires puisque nous allons créer
dans le code pénal un chapitre 2
exclusivement consacré à ses homicides
routiers ou blessures routières
vous avez raison Madame la Députée mal
nommer les choses comme le disait Camus
s'est aggravé les malheurs du monde et
il faut que les victimes se retrouvent
dans une véritable sémantique adaptée au
chagrin qui est le leur pour apporter
encore plus de cohérence et de
lisibilité dans le code pénal sur les
peines encourus en cas de missile
routier ces dispositions doivent être
intégrées dans ce nouveau chapitre qui
lui-même s'insère dans un titre de sur
les atteintes à la personne humaine bien
distincte des homicides involontaires
classiques vous savez ma détermination à
lutter contre les comportements routiers
les plus dangereux je sais pouvoir
compter sur votre entière mobilisation
pour qu'ensemble madame la députée grâce
à votre initiative nous puissions
changer la loi merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à Madame Soumia bouroua
pour le groupe GDR merci madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
où monsieur le ministre de la Santé en
juin 2020 les députés communistes et GDR
l'ancêtre une commission d'enquête sur
les conséquences de la covid sur la
jeunesse les conclusions faisaient état
d'une santé mentale préoccupante d'une
partie de nos enfants et d'un niveau de
prise en charge nettement insuffisants
professionnels de santé syndicat
étudiants équipes pédagogique tous
alertaient sur ce qui constituait une
bombe à retardement en effet la pandémie
n'a fait qu'aggraver les phénomènes
lourds préexistants harcèlement violence
intrafamiliale isolement social
comportement auto-destructeur sans que
les réponses suffisantes puissent être
trouvées
43% des étudiants sont en détresse
psychologique mais faute de moyens faute
de personnel dans les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur ils ne vont pas
consulter chez les plus petits la
situation n'est guère mieux avec 13% des
enfants de primaires présentant au moins
un trouble de santé mentale en disant le
nombre de pédopsychiatres à diminué de
plus d'un tiers alors que les besoins
n'ont jamais été aussi grands c'est
fragilité psychologique et les
comportements auto-destructeurs amènent
parfois aux violences quelquefois chez
de très jeunes individus la répression
ne peut constituer l'unique réponse à
des comportements et des souffrances qui
ne trouvent pas de remèdes fautes de
porte à pousser faute d'accompagnement
professionnel
monsieur le ministre madame la Première
ministre quel sera l'action du
gouvernement
afin d'augmenter le nombre de
pédopsychiatres en créant de nouveaux
postes et en valorisant le choix de la
spécialité de pédopsychiatrie dans le
cursus de formation de même comment
redonner le moyen au PMI mieux
accompagner les familles précaires et
enfin nous doter de tous les outils
nécessaires à la prise en charge de la
santé mentale de nos enfants je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
François brode ministre de la santé et
de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
bourrouard
la santé mentale de nos jeunes est un
enjeu majeur c'est un enjeu majeur et
prioritaire comme l'ont encore réaffirmé
récemment le président de la République
et la première ministre en jeu
prioritaire vous l'avez dit devant la
dégradation de cette santé mentale avec
encore un signal fort qui est arrivé
très récemment sur l'augmentation des
prescriptions de psychotropes chez les
plus jeunes et ce signal doit encore
nous interpeller enjeu majeur vous
l'avez dit la pédopsychiatrie est une
spécialité sinistrée sinistrée par des
décennies de gestion aveugle de nos
effectifs médicaux et vous le savez
comme moi il faut 10 ans pour un médecin
10 ans pour fabriquer entre guillemets
formés un pédopsychiatre et c'est bien
aujourd'hui sur l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé de la santé
mentale que nous devons nous appuyer
alors beaucoup est fait beaucoup va être
continué à être fait et renforcé la
stratégie des 1000 jours pour les plus
jeunes je n'y reviens pas le
renforcement des CMP un fantômes juvénil
le renforcement le déploiement continue
des des adolescents il y en a trois je
crois dans votre département ces maisons
des adolescents ont permis de prendre en
charge déjà 100.000 jeunes et leurs
familles également la création de postes
universitaires en pédopsychiatrie pour
rendre cette filière plus attractive et
faciliter la création de pédopsychiatre
la poursuite de mon soutien psy on dit
beaucoup de choses sur mon soutien psy
mais aujourd'hui ce sont 700 000
consultations qui ont été faites 145 000
patients pris en charge dont 20% qui
sont des jeunes et puis le dépistage de
dépistage est essentiel vous en avez
parlé nous nous appuyons aussi sur les
secouristes en santé mentale 50 000
aujourd'hui nous les déployons avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
toutes les écoles le plus rapidement
possible et également dans le milieu
sportif et associatif enfin il faut agir
sur les les bases de ces difficultés ce
sont le développement des compétences
psychosociales des enfants c'était
essentiel d'être plus jeune âge et nous
devrons en ce sens je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Marie-France
Loreau pour leur rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
monsieur le ministre c'est une
production d'excellence et un Florent de
notre cher Provence qui m'amène
aujourd'hui à vous interpeller pour
laquelle vous avez rencontré il y a peu
le sénateur Jean-Baptiste blanc la
filière des cerises est en danger de
mort des monts de Vénasque au coteau du
Ventoux le Vaucluse premier producteur
de ce fruit après près de 1000 tonnes de
cerises récoltées chaque année et
directement affectés par le fléau des
mouches Suzuki eragonetti serazi qui
ravage nos cerises il est des mots
monsieur le ministre que l'on peut
prévoir et que les caprices de la nature
ne nous permettent pas d'anticiper
d'autres en revanche sont attendus à
l'image des dérivés illégalistes et
évoquées par l'universitaire Daniel Dory
et engrangeant des actes des côtes
terrorisme à l'instar aussi de
l'acharnement idéologique d'une Union
européenne prête à sacrifier toute une
part de la production alimentaire de ces
pays membres au nom d'une pratique
supposée écologiquement vertueuse le 15
décembre 2020 j'avais Inter votre
prédécesseur par courrier pour
l'enfermer des graves dangers encourus
par la filière en cas de non
renouvellement du fossemètre produit
phytosanitaire irremplaçable dans la
lutte contre la mouche asiatique le
résultat est là cette année les
producteurs de cerises de Vaucluse
accuse 70 à 90 % de perte de leur
production ce constat dramatique doit
nous enjoindre à réagir les filets
placés au-dessus des productions sont
extrêmement coûteux et ne peuvent pas
être endagés comme le seul outil par
ailleurs je m'inquiète monsieur le
ministre que l'interdiction de ce
produit sur la filière européenne ne
s'adresse pas aux pays exportateur de
cerise qui n'ont pas les mêmes
obligations que nos producteurs français
et peuvent vendre à moindre coût à notre
pays des produits contenant des
phytosanitaires que nous banissons c'est
de la concurrence déloyale et un choix
douteux en terme écologique et de santé
publique alors que le respect de ces
règles devrait nous enjoindre à produire
et à consommer français il est
redoutable que favoriser les circuits
courts soient aujourd'hui bien plus
onéreux que d'importer des tonnes de
fruits de l'étranger s'il n'est pas
appliquer la préférence française à
l'égard de tel
[Applaudissements]
pour couvrir les pertes qui sont celles
des producteurs et leurs permettent de
passer ce cap qui est un pack difficile
mais deuxième élément il faut qu'on
travaille sur le moyen et le long terme
c'est à dire qu'on trouve des
alternatives aux produits
phytosanitaires si vous me permet un
point de désaccord avec vous le fausset
et le dimetoa sont des produits qui ont
été interdits pour des sujets de santé
publique y compris pour les applicateurs
c'est la décision la décision n'est pas
une sur transposition européenne c'est
une décision européenne qui s'applique à
l'ensemble des pays européens alors on a
besoin d'accélérer sur la recherche et
les innovations vous ne nous trouverez
pas sur le chemin dans rabat quand il
s'agit de question de santé publique et
d'environnement parce que sinon on
s'engage dans une voie qui me semble une
voie très dangereuse on a besoin vous
avez raison en revanche d'accélérer sur
les alternatives les alternatives sur
quoi aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est les
insectes stériles les alternatives c'est
la couverture des vergers qui peuvent
l'être mais il y a un surcoût qui est
important c'est pour ça que dans le plan
de souveraineté fruits et légumes nous
prévoyons des moyens pour accélérer la
transition des vergers et faire en sorte
qu'on donne des perspectives aux
producteurs de cerises comme à d'autres
secteur de l'arboriculture qui sont
touchés par ces difficultés là l'urgence
et le moyen et long terme la recherche
et l'innovation pour trouver des
solutions alternatives qui soient
crédibles et crédibles ça veut dire
crédiblement
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à madame Martin Froget pour
le groupe yote
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé monsieur le ministre nous avons
été nombreux ici à vous interpeller sur
une désertification médicale qui
s'aggrave sur de nombreux territoires et
qui se déportent à présent vers les
hôpitaux et leurs services d'urgence par
un territoire notamment dans les zones
rurales n'étaient épargnées par
l'avalanche de défections de médecins
accentuée par la loi riste tous les
clignotants sont au rouge cette
situation devient insupportable à vivre
pour les patients et insoutenables à
porter pour les élus qui se battent au
quotidien et c'est le cas en arrière mon
collègue Laurent Pagny food vous
interroger encore récemment sur le
risque de fermeture des urgences des
deux centres hospitaliers de l'Ariège
depuis aucune initiative ni amélioration
pire de nouvelles fermetures de services
arrivent aujourd'hui en cascade
qualifiée par euphémisme de suspension
temporaire c'est le cas de la l'éternité
de Saint-Girons qui vient d'annoncer une
fermeture de 15 jours au grande arme des
parturianes qui apprennent consterné
qu'elles devront aller consulter et
accoucher à plus de 50 minutes de
voiture
l'inquiétude et l'incompréhension sont
alors combles sur un territoire qui n'en
finit pas de subir cette désertification
galopante monsieur le ministre la
situation n'est plus tenable certes vous
avez engagé un certain nombre de
réformes mais dans la réalité nos
concitoyens ne voient aucune
amélioration et la dégradation de
l'offre de soins s'amplifie pourtant des
solutions existent encore faut-il les
mettre en oeuvre et je pense notamment à
la mutualisation qui peut se faire à
l'échelle régionale aussi ma question
est la suivante quand allez-vous enfin
entendre les propositions
transpartisanes sur l'introduction d'une
forme de régulation de l'accès aux soins
quelle mesure entendez-vous prendre à
court terme pour assurer concrètement
la continuité du service public de santé
je vous remercie ma chère collègues la
parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Martine Froget nous sommes effectivement
d'accord sur le diagnostic nous manquons
de professionnels de santé sur
l'ensemble du territoire national et
pour former un médecin je le redis c'est
dix ans donc nous n'aurons pas de
solution miracle dans les les mois et
les années qui viennent les axes que
nous développons sur ces solutions c'est
redonner plus de temps aux
professionnels plus de temps auprès du
patient et les engager dans une logique
territoriale pour mieux répondre aux
besoins de santé de notre population
alors je ne referai pas ici avec vous le
débat que nous avons eu très riche
d'ailleurs dans cette hémicycle sur la
coercition ou non à l'installation des
médecins généralistes je rappellerai ce
que j'ai déjà dit elle est
contre-productive je reviendrai puisque
vous avez parlé des maternités et des
services d'urgence
je comprends bien sûr l'enjeu pour les
territoires tout à chacun préfère
accoucher au plus près de chez soi tout
à chacun préfère être pris en charge par
les urgences au plus proche de chez soi
mais ma ligne est simple dans cette
organisation c'est d'associer sécurité
et proximité avec la sécurité d'abord et
la sécurité c'est garantir aux Français
qui passe la porte d'un service
d'urgence qui seront correctement pris
en charge pour les urgences réelles et
vitales et c'est garantir aux femmes qui
veulent accoucher qu'elles pourront
accoucher dans des conditions de
sécurité totale pour elle et pour le
tranchant dans ce cadre là nous mettons
en place avec les élus à l'échelle de
chaque territoire les solutions les plus
adaptées en fonction des moyens dont
nous disposons je rappellerai simplement
pour le cas des urgences non pas la
fermeture dont beaucoup de gens parlent
mais qui est dans l'immense majorité des
cas ce que l'on appelle un accès régulé
régulé par l'appel préalable au 15 si
l'on concitoyens pensent qu'ils ont un
problème d'urgence pour qu'on leur donne
la meilleure solution et la meilleure
solution n'est pas d'aller
systématiquement vers le service
d'urgence elle peut être aussi d'aller
voir un médecin généraliste vrai
d'ailleurs dans la campagne la
possibilité de visualiser très simple
près de chez vous les médecins
généralistes disponibles pour les soins
non programmés
la parole est à Madame Laurence Christol
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre la santé et de la
prévention
depuis un an et pour la première fois
nous avons un ministre de la prévention
cela marque une ambition et marque une
priorité face à l'augmentation des
pathologies chroniques pour nos jeunes
pour nos aînés en perte d'autonomie au
travail à l'école par le logement les
défis sont très nombreux et pour cause
la prévention est à la croisée de toutes
les dimensions de la vie de la santé et
les inégalités territoriales et sociales
restent fortes ceci peut expliquer
certaines impatience son pouvoir être
excis exhaustive je constate que depuis
six ans nous avons fait des progrès
considérables que ce soit sur la
politique de lutte contre le tabac la
santé sexuelle la vaccination ou les
1000 premiers jours de la vie de
l'enfant mais si la crise sanitaire a pu
freiner l'ambition des précédents
gouvernements les lignes ont aujourd'hui
bougé mais alors que de nombreux travaux
sont publiés depuis plus d'un an il nous
faut désormais accélérer je pense en
particulier au frein au développement de
l'activité physique adaptée au levier à
trouver pour mieux lutter contre
l'obésité ou à l'ambition d'une
génération sans tabac qui doit nous
conduire à mieux régulée les nouveaux
produits conçus par l'industrie les
prochains mois les prochaines années
doivent amener à des actions résolues et
structurées ma question est donc simple
un an après le début de cette
législature quel bilan tirez-vous de
votre action et quelles sont les
perspectives de votre ministère dans les
prochains mois pour accélérer les
virages préventifs de notre société
je vous remercie la parole est un
monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Laurence Cristol ministre de la santé et
de la prévention je fais bien entendu de
la prévention un objectif phare de la
politique du gouvernement
cette prévention nous avançons vers une
véritable révolution un changement de
paradigme voulu par le Président de la
République est conduit sous l'autorité
de la première ministre alors ce
changement de paradigme cette révolution
elle se développe dans deux axes un
premier axe qui est la politique de
aller vers aller vers nos concitoyens
qui sont les plus loin du soin
aujourd'hui parce que ce sont eux qui
vont bénéficier en premier de cette
politique de prévention aller vers par
le développement de la médiation en
santé aller vers par le déploiement de
centre communautaire de consultation
avancée et puis un certain nombre de
mesures ont été déployées et vont
continuer à se déployer sans vouloir
faire une liste à la Prévert je
reviendrai sur quelques points dans le
cadre de la santé sexuelle
la gratuité des préservatifs qui a
multiplié par trois leur utilisation la
vaccination contre le papillomavirus qui
va se déployer à partir de la rentrée à
partir de septembre dans les classes de
5e auprès de 800000 élèves nous avons là
une
occasion historique de faire disparaître
en 20 ans le cancer du col de l'utérus
qui tue mille femmes par an et qui en
entraîne quatre fois plus dans des
pathologies cancéreuses également le
sport santé vous l'avez évoqué nous
tenons ce sport santé le déploiement des
maisons sport santé se poursuit ainsi
que l'évolution de la prescription de
l'activité physique adaptée et enfin les
rendez-vous de prévention alors comme la
prévention on en a beaucoup parlé on a
parlé dans le PLFSS et je suis ravi de
pouvoir vous annoncer ici que nous
débattons les rendez-vous prévention au
1er octobre prochain prioritairement
auprès de la tranche d'âge des 45 50 ans
qui sont les plus concernés et vers
lesquels nous allons aller en priorité
pour proposer des parcours de santé
complet et puis à la rentrée le nouveau
plan de lutte contre le tabac continuera
à nous permettre de nous battre contre
ce fléau qui tue encore 75000 personnes
par an
merci Monsieur le Ministre la parole est
à Madame Daniel Simonet pour le groupe
la France insoumise madame la présidente
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers collègues le rapport de la
commission d'enquête uber-files a été
rendue publique aujourd'hui il confirme
que la plateforme américaine uber a
érigé l'île l'égalité en mode de
fonctionnement des nouveaux documents
accablants transmis par le silenceur
d'alerte Marc Magan démontre à quel
point Emmanuel Macron a été un soutien
précieux pour Hubert lorsqu'il était
ministre de l'Économie allant jusqu'à
conclure un deal et réduire
drastiquement les conditions de
formation des VTC et échanges échanger
un arrêté préfectoral la commission
également qui était sur le développement
de l'ubérisation de 2017 à aujourd'hui
et l'action des pouvoirs publics madame
la Première ministre les décisions de
justice confirment la réalité des liens
de subordination des travailleurs des
plateformes et donc l'illégalité du
recours au statut d'indépendant et la
nécessité de leur requalification
salarié
une note de 2019 du ministère du travail
démontre que le gouvernement a
pleinement connaissance de l'étendue du
développement de l'ubérisation dans les
secteurs aussi déchirants que la
restauration le funéraire l'aide aux
personnes la santé et le BTP le tourisme
les auto-écoles le transform
maritinariat et j'en passe et dans tous
ces domaines la note est accablante les
plateformes sont hors la loi et piétine
le code du travail leurs obligations
sociales et fiscales et les
réglementations sectorielles et après
qu'avez-vous fait pour faire respecter
l'État de droit l'enquête des mondes
qu'il n'y a eu aucune impulsion
politique pour cibler les plateformes
donnez les moyens aux administrations de
contrôle pire l'action de l'exécutif
depuis 2017 vise uniquement à protéger
les plateformes du risque de
requalification en salariés au mépris du
droit quel message envoyez-vous
entrevise qui subissent ces concurrences
déloyales allez-y à votre tour ext
ernalisez vos salariés en
auto-entrepreneur ne payez pas l'URSSAF
et faites de l'évasion fiscale quel est
donc votre projet de société
et le retour
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail de l'insertion et du
plein emploi merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs le députés madame
la député Simonet que de mensonges en 2
minutes que de mensonges
vous dites madame la députée qu'il
aurait un deal sacré le rapport que de
la commission d'enquête dont vous êtes
vous-même leur rapporteur ne montre rien
de tout cela vous dites que les
décisions de justice donnent raison à la
thèse qui est la vôtre il y a un certain
nombre de procédures qui ont été
intentées par des travailleurs de
plateforme moins d'un jugement sur deux
à amené une requalification vous dites
madame la députée que l'organisation du
travail de plateforme dans notre pays ne
produit aucun droit nous en sommes à 5
accords collectifs pour protéger les
travailleurs des plateformes pour
permettre de fixer un prix minimum pour
organiser la représentativité vous dites
que le gouvernement fait obstacle à la
conclusion et l'adoption d'une directive
européenne j'étais présent au Conseil
des ministres et j'ai voté pour la
directive chacune des assertions chacune
des affirmations qui sont les vôtres
sont au mieux des mensonges ou au pire
relève du complotisme je reprends
volontiers à mon compte les mots du
président de la commission d'enquête
président de la commission d'enquête qui
dit que dans votre rôle de rapporteur
vous avez été de parti pris que les
propositions que vous faites ne sont que
copier-coller du programme de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon que vous avez eu vous-même une
attitude qui fruse avec le complotisme
en audition madame la députée vous tirez
de votre apport des conclusions qui ne
portent pas vous êtes dans l'affirmation
vous êtes dans l'incantation et en
réalité vous vous éloignez de la réalité
le seul objectif que vous poursuivez
madame la députée c'est de nourrir une
forme de diversion pour faire oublier
les errements de votre famille politique
votre rapport est creux et c'est bien là
la difficulté pour vous vous pensiez
trouver un complot vous n'avez trouvé
que le droit et la loi
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame Isabelle Valentin
pour le groupe les républicains merci
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur le ministre notre système de
santé est à bout de souffle et vous
restez aveuglé sourd nous soignants en
établissements et en ville sont épuisés
ils sont là s'ils sont démotivés et ils
ne se retrouvent plus dans leur métier
le manque cruel de médecins se fait
sentir dans tous les services c'est
surtout les territoires aujourd'hui la
majorité de nos EHPAD sont déficitaires
à titre d'exemple en Haute-Loire des
déficits vont de 60 000 euros à 130 000
euros pour 2022 concernant 2023 ces
chiffres seront catastrophiques avec des
déficits en moyenne de 300.000 euros
c'est accablant mais personne dans ce
gouvernement ne prend la mesure du
problème
face à cela les établissements de santé
sont forcés de rééquilibrer leur compte
au détriment de la qualité du soin
suppression de poste suppression des
postes d'animateurs d'ergothérapeute
réduction du coût de l'alimentation
fermeture d'unités de cantou
malheureusement la liste est longue et
nos aînés vont en faire les frais vous
le savez le coup du Ségur l'avenant 43
l'augmentation du point d'indice ainsi
que l'explosion des charges constituent
les principaux causes de cette situation
alarmante dans lequel notre système de
santé se trouve actuellement
ces dernières semaines vous nous
proposez un texte bien vieillir mais
Monsieur le Ministre renonçait à une
véritable loi sur le grand âge et
autonomie qui est attendu depuis six ans
reste un choix politique purement
financier qui vous incombe le texte que
vous nous proposez n'est absolument ne
correspond absolument pas à ce
qu'attendre les professionnels de santé
du domicile les personnes âgées et leurs
familles il ne s'agit ni plus ni moins
d'une coquille vide impossible à amender
et qui n'est pas à la hauteur des enjeux
du Bien vieillir
en effet les prévisions sont unanimes
face au vieillissement de la population
les besoins des professions médicales et
paramédicales ne vont cesser d'augmenter
ces dernières années quid des formations
adaptées aberration de parcoursup sur
ces métiers là mais Monsieur le Ministre
quelle place voulez-vous donc donner à
nos aînés dans notre société merci
beaucoup ma chère collègues la parole
est à Monsieur Jean-Christophe combe
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
des personnes handicapées
merci merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Valentin je
vous remercie votre pour votre question
qui me permet de rappeler quel est
l'ambition du gouvernement pour nous
aider depuis le 1er jour de ma
nomination je suis au côté des
établissements pour les soutenir dans
une période particulièrement difficile
vous l'avez dit des difficultés
économiques et c'est pour ça que nous
avons délégué en fin d'année 440
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaires c'est pour ça que la loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
prévoit une augmentation des budgets de
plus de 5% pour nos EHPAD c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé aux ARS avec les
départements d'agir aux côtés et d'être
aux côtés des opérateurs pour pour
pouvoir les soutenir avec des crédits et
de pouvoir également mesurer la
situation dans laquelle ils sont pour
que avec les départements on puisse
apporter des réponses qui soient à la
hauteur de la situation à court terme à
moyen terme j'ai mis en place un groupe
de travail avec les départements pour
travailler sur le modèle économique des
EHPAD dont les conclusions seront
enrichies par la mission de Madame pires
bonne sur la question du reste à charge
en EHPAD pour assurer l'accessibilité de
l'offre à nos aînés donc nous sommes
bien à leurs côtés par ailleurs vous
faites état de la proposition de loi du
Bien vieillir et vous le savez bien elle
ne reflète pas la toute l'ambition que
porte le gouvernement sur sur cette
question nous avons et j'ai porté une
réflexion dans le cadre du CNR d'un CNR
dédié au bien vieillir qui a fait
l'objet de conclusion en avril je
présenterai une feuille de route
interministériel qui portera notre
ambition pour adapter la société dans
toutes ces dimensions au défi du
vieillissement que nous devons relever
tous ensemble
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre la
parole est à Monsieur Bertrand Bouix
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame
madame la Présidente mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Madame Catherine
Colonna ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères
madame le ministre dans le contexte de
guerre au cœur même de notre vieux
continent suite à l'agression de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine le rôle parfois
méconnu du Conseil de l'Europe n'en
reste pas moins essentiel
pour ces missions de défense des droits
de l'homme en effet la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme signé
par 46 états protège aujourd'hui plus de
700 millions d'Européens
j'ai l'honneur de présider la délégation
française à l'Assemblée parlementaire du
Conseil de l'Europe et j'en profite ici
pour saluer tous ces membres pour leur
travail pour leur engagement
sur tous les bancs assemblés Sénat
merci à eux pour le travail exemplaire
accompli autour de cette année
comme la déclaré le président de la
République au quatrième sommet des
chèques d'État à Reykjavik le 16 mai
dernier un seul lieu nous permet d'agir
pour la sécurité démocratique de notre
continent le Conseil de l'Europe à
l'occasion de ce sommet historique une
feuille de route commune a été tracée la
France et le Conseil de l'Europe ont
réaffirmé leur soutien sans faille à
l'Ukraine
un registre les dommages causé par
l'agression de la Fédération de Russie
contre le contre l'Ukraine a été créé
et la volonté politique est aujourd'hui
de créer un tribunal spécial
international pour juger les crimes de
guerre commis par la Russie
dans la ville martyrdirpine comme de
nombreux députés sénateurs ayant pu se
rendre en Ukraine nous avons pu
constater les blessures infligées par
les soldats russes au peuple ukrainien
alors Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous
nous détailler devant la représentation
nationale quelle part en prendre la
France dans ce processus visant à faire
reconnaître les crimes de la Russie et
permettent l'indemnisation des victimes
je vous remercie merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier belge le
ministre chargé du Commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité et des Français de
l'étranger
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Bertrand Bouix la
France réitère sa condamnation de
l'agression injustifiée et illégal de la
Russie contre l'Ukraine la Russie doit
rendre des comptes et nous soutiendrons
l'Ukraine aussi longtemps qu'il le
faudra c'est le message constant qui est
ressorti des rendez-vous internationaux
qui se sont succédés au cours des
dernières semaines qu'il s'agit du
sommet du G7 du Conseil européen ou du
sommet de l'OTAN nous avons saisi sans
délai
soutien humain et financier au
juridictions ukrainiennes et à la Cour
pénale internationale pour leurs
enquêtes sur les crimes commis par la
Russie contre les victimes ukrainiennes
car comme la rappeler la ministre
Catherine Colonna hier audacieux unis à
l'occasion du 25e anniversaire du Statut
de Rome il ne peut pas y avoir de paix
sans justice ni en Ukraine ni nulle part
ailleurs alors vous évoquez en
particulier l'action du Conseil de
l'Europe et je voudrais rendre hommage à
la délégation française que vous
présidez à l'Assemblée parlementaires du
Conseil de l'Europe et à l'ensemble de
cette institution le Conseil de l'Europe
a su ajur vite en excluant la Russie de
l'organisation dès le 16 mars 2022 il
s'est porté sans délai aux côtés de
l'Ukraine des ukrainiennes et ukrainiens
pour accompagner sa résilience et ses
efforts pour renforcer encore l'État de
droit et l'aider à lutter contre
l'impunité des criminels russes lors du
sommet de Reykjavik les 16 et 17 mai
auquel le président de la République a
participé au cours du le président qui
est intervenu en visioconférence le
Conseil de l'Europe a marqué à nouveau
son soutien à l'Ukraine en créant un
registre des dommages causés par
l'agression russe le registre qui répond
à une demande de l'Ukraine et de
l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU permettra
de recenser de documenter les dommages
perte ou préjudice subies par les
victimes de l'agression de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine tous les pays peuvent
adhérer y compris ce qui ne sont pas
membres du Conseil de l'Europe le Regis
sera ainsi bientôt fonctionnel et c'est
ainsi que nous punirons les criminels
russes et demanderont la réparation des
domaines
la parole est à Madame anapick pour le
groupe socialiste merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
madame la secrétaire d'État auprès du
ministre des Armées chargée de la
jeunesse et du service national
universel face à nos interrogations et
réticences vous nous avez invité à nous
rendre sur le terrain pour voir de nos
propres yeux la réalité du SNU j'ai donc
suivi votre recommandation et le constat
est déroutant je veux croire que ce
n'est pas partout comme ça nous sommes
loin des enjeux proclamés à grand
renforts de communication tels que le
développement de la mixité sociale
l'appréhension des valeurs de la
République et l'engagement au service de
la nation parce que le moment m'a laissé
muette pendant une minute je reprends
ici les propos du premier tuteur
rencontrés qui à la vue de ma carte de
visite s'est exclamé à mais je connais
l'Assemblée nationale je l'ai visité
avant d'assumer je n'ai pas voté aux
législatif moi je vote que pour les
présidentielles
la responsable du séjour nous en
expliquent ensuite les activités levée
de couleur marseillaise théâtre
baby-foot balade visite culturelle et
intervention de l'armée ou de la
gendarmerie les objectifs présentés en
réalité sont assez similaires à ce déjà
validés par le sable des élèves en fin
de la classe de 3e à ceci près qu'ils ne
sont pas transmis par des gens formés à
cela et que le budget qui est consacré
et particulièrement important on m'a
annoncé 700 euros par jeune or
hébergement et restauration enfin à mon
interrogation à propos des attentes des
jeunes et du sens qu'ils mettent dans
les symboles mis en avant comme le
drapeau ou la Marseillaise le silence de
l'encadrante est à la fois profond et
gêné on parle des valeurs de la France
me dit-elle bien en fait on évoque la
devise nationale mais dans le désordre
et avec la plus grande hésitation j'ai
quitté évidemment le site assez concerné
avec le ressenti que le SMU s'apparente
à une colonie de vacances inadaptée aux
enjeux
madame la ministre ne serait-il pas tant
au regard des dispositifs alloués
d'abandonner ce dispositif aussi coûteux
qui n'adapté et de transférer les
crédits à l'éducation nationale et à
l'éducation populaire acteur plus à même
de répondre aux défis en jeu que vous
souhaitez relever la parole est à Madame
Sarah elle Airi secrétaire d'État chargé
de la jeunesse et du service national
universel
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
à nappy je vous remercie d'avoir pris le
temps d'aller à la rencontre de cette
jeunesse engagée qui a fait le choix de
prendre 15 jours pour développer son
esprit civique citoyen de vivre des
temps de patriotisme madame la députée
et je suis particulièrement heureuse de
cette démarche de votre part parce que
la l'honnêteté d'aller à leur rencontre
de découvrir aussi que 57% des jeunes
qui ont fait le SNU sont des jeunes
filles que plus de 6% sont des jeunes
qui viennent des quartiers populaires et
qu'en réalité madame la députée plus que
pour nous ce n'est pas un sujet lever un
drapeau lever le drapeau français est
une chance ça crée de l'unité des bas
donnent des valeurs de la République
c'est en complémentarité avec les
travaux qui sont faits et mener par les
enseignants au sein de l'éducation
nationale madame la député vous savez il
n'y a point d'investissement
excessif pour notre jeunesse des
parlementaires de l'ensemble des bancs
madame adoptée des députés des députés
de l'ensemble
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous taire et laisser parler
la ministre des députés des députés de
l'ensemble des bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale sont partis visiter en réalité
des séjours plus de 40 000 jeunes ont
fait un séjour de et c'est nous cette
année 10000 sont sur liste d'attente en
réalité d'année en année madame c'est un
succès qui prend tranquillement et qui
fait ses preuves madame la députée vous
savez il n'y a rien de plus fort en tout
cas à mes yeux que de voir une jeunesse
qui n'était jamais sorti de son
département
osé quitter son département être dans un
dortoir manger la même chose découvrir
mais s'il vous plaît
intellectuelle apportée n'opposez pas
éducation populaire et service national
universel plus que jamais un tiers des
encadrants du service national universel
viennent de l'éducation populaire la
Ligue de l'enseignement accueille Léo
Lagrange accueille les Francas accueille
un tiers de nos qui ont servi sous nos
drapeaux gendarmes et encore des
enseignants merci madame je vous
remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Christophe
Plassard pour le groupe horizon merci
madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale
monsieur le ministre lundi 4 septembre
prochain 12 millions d'élèves rentreront
sur les bancs de l'école dont 46470 en
Charente-Maritime soit une baisse
d'environ 700 élèves sur une année elle
entraîne une recomposition importante
des cartes scolaires notamment en zone
rurale que nous savons fragilisés
démographiquement et dont il faut
renforcer l'attractivité
53 fermetures de classe ont été
annoncées dans le département contre
seulement 11 ouvertures nous savons
comme l'école est centrale dans nos
villages elle est vectrice de maintien
des commerces de services à la personne
de lien social cette baisse du nombre
d'enfants entre un une baisse logique du
nombre de classes attention cependant à
ce que ce soit pas synonyme de baisse de
la qualité de l'enseignement tout
particulièrement en zone rurale
au niveau local les fermetures de classe
peuvent aboutir à une surpopulation des
classes restantes entraînant la baisse
du niveau d'enseignement et une
détérioration de la qualité de la vie
des enfants même si de nombreuses
mesures sont déployées pour cette
rentrée comme l'élargissement de
l'expérimentation territoire éducatif
ruraux le dédoublement des classes dans
les zones quartiers prioritaires des
politiques de la ville a prouvé sa
pertinence peut-on envisager son
application dans la ruralité au niveau
national les problématiques de
recrutement peuvent faire craindre un
manque d'enseignement d'enseignants
pardon dans cette optique et vous le
rappelez dans votre circulaire de
rentrée le gouvernement a porté des
mesures volontaristes en 2022 et 2023
notamment une revalorisation inédite des
salaires des professeurs
monsieur le ministre pourriez-vous nous
préciser comment le gouvernement
accompagne les académies pour s'assurer
que cette rentrée scolaire se déroule
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
qu'il y ait bien un professeur devant
chaque classe sous l'angle du bon
rapport nombre d'élèves nombre
d'enseignants en particulier en zone
rurale je vous remercie je vous remercie
mon cher collègue la parole est à
Monsieur papenda ministre de l'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse merci madame
la Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député Christophe
plassa les territoires ruraux en
prolongement de votre question est une
double caractéristique l'éloignement et
la faible densité d'une part et d'autre
part la baisse des effectifs scolaires
moins 500 élèves dans votre département
de Charente-Maritime nous nous sommes
engagés à ce que le taux d'encadrement
s'améliore de fait il va légèrement
s'améliorer en passant sous les 22
élèves par classe dans votre département
mais nous devons faire plus
incontestablement et c'est tout l'objet
du plan ruralité qui a été annoncé par
la première ministre il y a quelques
mois de quoi s'agit-il les maires des
communes rurales demandent de la
visibilité et demande à ce que la carte
scolaire ne soit pas modifiée en février
pour la rentrée nous nous engageons donc
à ce que une instance de concertation
puisse regarder cette carte scolaire sur
trois ans parce que les enfants qui
naissent aujourd'hui seront scolarisés
dans trois ans en tenant compte
évidemment des mouvements annuels de
population et donc on ne s'agit pas de
geler la carte scolaire mais il s'agit
de donner de la visibilité aux maires et
c'est bien ce qu'il réclame par ailleurs
vous faites allusion à la perte
d'attractivité du métier à laquelle nous
répondons d'abord par des hausses
significatives de salaire entre 8 et 11%
pour les 7 premiers échelons de carrière
plus les 1,5% annoncés pour tous les
fonctionnaires et je note que le nombre
admis au concours s'améliore cette année
plus 8,2% en ce qui concerne le premier
degré ça n'est pas suffisant nous avons
encore du chemin à parcourir mais cela
permet de préparer la rentrée dans des
conditions qui s'annoncent
satisfaisantes je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à Madame André torignat
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
solidarité
40% des gens ne partiront pas en France
en vacances cette année 63% d'ouvriers
ces trois fois plus que les cadres la
raison la baisse du pouvoir d'achat
l'augmentation des loyers celle des prix
des produits de première nécessité que
vous et le RN avez refusé de bloquer
quand nous vous le proposions c'est les
salaires que vous n'avez pas voulu
augmenter pour attraper l'inflation pour
tout ce vivant dans la précarité pour
les enfants qui n'ont pas la chance
d'avoir des grands-parents à la retraite
et cela seront encore plus nombreux l'an
prochain à cause de votre réforme les
vacances ça reste du rêve les centres
sociaux permettraient d'adoucir leur été
toute l'année ces espaces créent du lien
social prennent le relais des services
publics que vous détruisez petit à petit
permettent l'expression pacifique de la
parole des citoyens ils offrent des
activités culturelles et sportives aux
enfants comme aux parents précieux ils
deviennent indispensables pendant les
vacances scolaires surtout en été pour
ses enfants et ses ados contraints de
rester chez eux par vos choix politiques
mais les centres sociaux crient au
secours fragilisés par un
sous-financement chronique par votre
logique délétère d'appel à projet et par
une crise profonde des métiers du
secteur social il subissent eux aussi de
plein fouet les conséquences de
l'inflation ils ont déjà raboté tout ce
qui pouvait être rabotés aujourd'hui on
arrive à l'os la Fédération des Centres
sociaux de la Loire a réalisé une
projection comptable sur l'année 2023
2024 le constat est dramatique sans en
soutien massif au niveau national de
nombreux centres sociaux vont baisser le
rideau et ceux des quartiers les plus
fragiles seront les premiers concernés
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre
clarifier la ligne de la convention
d'objectifs et de gestion de la sécurité
sociale en matière d'augmentation des
prestations des centres soci aux je vous
remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe combe ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députés André
thorignat en tant qu'humiste en charge
de la petite enfance et des familles je
ne peux que partager avec vous la pensée
que vous avez pour toutes ces familles
c'est millions de familles qui partent
aujourd'hui en vacances et celles qui ne
le pourront malheureusement pas
pour des raisons diverses et il faut
jamais et il faut jamais se résigner non
je ne suis pas d'accord avec vous parce
que nous agissons cette année encore
avec les collectivités locales et avec
les acteurs associatifs le gouvernement
fera en sorte d'aider autant d'enfants
que possible à profiter de ces moments
de respiration et d'épanouissement
personnel ça n'enjeu d'équilibre entre
vie professionnelle et vie personnelle
pour les parents et d'accès pour les
enfants à des temps de sociabilisation à
ce titre vous avez fait référence la
nouvelle convention d'objectif et de
gestion entre l'État et la CNAF que j'ai
signé il y a quelques jours prévoit un
effort significatif en faveur de l'accès
aux vacances les quatre renforceront
leur investissement dans les structures
d'accueil périscolaire et extra-scolaire
avec plus 12% d'heures d'accueil financé
et 410 nouveaux animateurs qualifiés
prévus c'est un vrai investissement
cette cause elle est historique pour que
tous les enfants puissent être
accueillis sans distinction par ailleurs
le bonus inclusif a par ailleurs été
généralisé dans l'accueil collectif des
mineurs c'était une une annonce forte
portée par la Conférence nationale du
handicap ces efforts ils viennent
compléter l'action de mes collègues ça
réeleri entre en ce qui concerne les
colos apprenantes depuis le début c'est
plus de 250 000 enfants qui ont pu en
bénéficier et Olivia Grégoire qui avait
annoncé dès avril la hausse des moyens
de l'Agence Nationale des
chèques-vacances vous m'interrogez enfin
sur le soutien au centre socio qui
assure à la fois l'accompagnement des
familles et des jeunes mais aussi
l'accès aux droits et la lutte contre le
non recours j'y tiens c'est centre socio
sur ton coeur de cette nouvelle
convention d'objectifs et de gestion les
CAF développeront 600 nouvelles
structures d'animation à la vie sociale
entre 2023 et 2027 tout en revalorisant
et en pérennisant celle qui sont
existantes en renforçant leur
financement on est donc clairement à
leur côté
la parole est à Monsieur Francis Dubois
pour le gonflet public
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre manger
des pommes et mes répéter Jacques Chirac
en vantant la pomme corrézienne or la
pomme française est en danger la filière
est attaquée de toutes parts et les
nuisibles sont plus réelles d'abord des
invasions massives de pucerons sans
précédent dévastent nos vergers de plus
des normes françaises trop
contraignantes impact nos pomiculteurs
alors que l'Union européenne européenne
pardon réglemente l'utilisation et
autorise une liste de produits
phytosanitaires la France elle fidèle à
sa tradition de surtransposition
interdit ces mêmes interactives et
pénalise les producteurs qui ne
disposent que de traitement
phytosanitaires
inefficaces dans les coups de production
sont multipliés par 3 notre souveraineté
alimentaire passe par des règles
homogènes face aux pucerons le verger
français doit être traité comme le
verger italien ou polonais nous ne
pouvoir laisser nos agriculteurs dans le
désarroi même en Corrèze les grossistes
apportent massivement de Pologne des
pommes traitées avec les produits
interdits en France servi ensuite dans
les assiettes de nos écoliers de nos
collégiens de nos aînés en EHPAD et ceux
au prix d'un bilan carbone déficitaire
nous marchons sur la tête pomme de la
discorde sont légion nos vergers sont
aussi victimes de nuisibles écologistes
ravageurs encore la semaine dernière
dans le Tarn plus de 9000 pommiers ont
été arrachés saccagés dans quel monde
vit-on
90% d'un verger détruit par des
commandos écologistes alors que face à
la dureté du marché bio ou seule la
moitié de la production des pommes bio
est valorisée les producteurs se
trouvent contraint de s'adapter en
revenant en agriculture conventionnelle
monsieur le ministre sur la question des
traitements appliquant les règles de
l'Union européenne stoppant
immédiatement l'assuranchir normative et
punitive à la française proposant 100
délais à nos pomiculteurs des
engagements concrets et durables et face
aux attaques répétées incendies
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Marc penaud ministre de l'Agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire merci
beaucoup madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député Dubois vous avez raison la terre
de Corrèze est une terre pour des tas de
raisons qui vendent la pomme il y a
trois éléments dans le de réponse que je
voulais vous faire le premier élément de
réponse d'abord dénoncé comme vous les
actes de destruction de bien d'autrui
revendiquer sous le couvert évidemment
de l'anonymat qui pose quand même une
question sur les intentions finales d'un
certain nombre de ces gens il faut s'en
relâche dénoncer ses actes la justice
est saisie la police et la gendarmerie
de travail pour trouver les éthers les
auteurs et les mettre devant les
tribunaux
tout ça procède aussi de tous les
discours qu'on voit sur le terrain d'un
certain nombre de gens qui viennent
opposer les agricultures le modèle
conventionnel le modèle bio et c'est ça
qu'on l'a sous les yeux quand les mots
sont violents la violence naît et donc
j’allerte les uns et les autres sur le
fait que attention à ce qu'on dit les
uns les autres sur l'agriculture et la
nécessité de défendre toutes les
agricultures y compris dans la nécessité
des transitions deuxième élément on a
besoin vous avez raison de raisonner en
européen je l'ai déjà dit c'est la
volonté de la première minute il y a pas
de surtransposition arrêtons les
surtranspositions et nous croyons pas
toujours que nous serions français tout
seul sur une île quand nous sommes dans
un marché commun ou dans un marché
unique ça nécessite aussi que quand nous
avons des règles européennes c'est ce
que nous poussons au niveau européen il
y a des clauses miroir ça me permet de
compléter ce que je n'ai pas dit à
Madame l'euro il faut des close miroir
mais ça ne peut se faire que si nous
avons des règles européennes et enfin
nous avons besoin je le dis sur cette
filière comme d'autres de sortir du
logique molécule par molécule mais de
raisonner et c'est le sens du plan
Écophyto et du travail que nous menons
sous l'égide de la première ministre
d'avoir une planification sur les
molécules de regarder les usages de
regarder les en passe éventuelles et de
mettre des moyens sur la recherche
d'innovation ce que nous faisons
massivement d'ailleurs au trapé au
travers du plan France 2030 et puis il y
a un dernier élément vous avez commencé
par cela c'est aussi un acte de
consommateur auquel j'appelle nous
travaillons actuellement dans les
cantines pour développer la consommation
de pommes comme vous le saviez nous
avons du retard sur un programme
européen mais nous avons besoin d'un
deuxième sujet c'est que chacun se
centrer responsable de la filière et que
nous puissions adapter la promotion de
la filière pomme dans les grandes
surfaces et dans la consommation chez
les Français merci je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Pascal Lavergne pour le groupe
Renaissance
je vous remercie madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé depuis plusieurs jours maintenant
les producteurs de vin de spiritueux et
de bière s'inquiètent d'une modification
de la fiscalité sur l'alcool et
notamment d'un relèvement des droits
d'accyse la filière 20 est des
spiritueux ainsi que la bière représente
50 milliards de chiffre d'affaires ce
secteur d'excellence française et le
second contributeur à la balance
commerciale avec un solde commercial de
près de 16 milliards la viticulture
c'est près de 650 000 emplois dans les
territoires non délocalisables sur 20
000 communes et 66 départements en
nombre de brasseries la France est le
premier en Europe et le deuxième dans le
monde la viticulture la brasserie les
spiritueux sont des secteurs en pleine
crise de compétitivité en effet le
contexte actuel est particulièrement
difficile pour eux Chris géopolitique
crise sanitaire aléa climatique pris de
l'énergie prix inflation sur les
matières sèches ces difficultés s'en
servent partout en Gironde dans mon
département aujourd'hui ces difficultés
sont exacerbées en raison des ravages du
milieu
ces crises à répétitions sont venus
fragiliser l'ensemble d'un secteurs et
une augmentation de la fiscalité agavrer
une situation économique déjà dégradée
depuis 2017 la majorité
œuvre vaut la compétitivité de nos
entreprises et de nos filières une
augmentation de la fiscalité viendrait
mettre sous pression une des rares
filières exportatrices son soutien de la
majorité à cette filière ne vaut pas
négociation des enjeux de santé publique
lié à la consommation d'alcool
aujourd'hui tous les indicateurs de
santé publique sont orientés à la baisse
la France qui était 13e pays et qui
était deuxième consommateur en 2016 et
aujourd'hui 13e une bière un vin et
monsieur le ministre nous avons partagé
un verre de Pessac Léognan lors de votre
venue à Bordeaux le 17 avril
c'est aussi notre notre tradition en
période de forte inflation cela risque
sûrement de pénaliser les plus faibles
monsieur le ministre envisagez-vous
envisagez-vous une taxation sur les
alcools la parole est à Monsieur
François beau nom ministre de la santé
et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Pascal Lavergne je vous remercie pour
votre question qui va me permettre de
clarifier nos pistes de travail en la
matière ce sujet je tiens tout d'abord à
saluer le travail qui a été conduit par
les députés de la commission des
affaires sociales et je pense en
particulier à Cyril isacybil qui a
produit un rapport sur ce sujet en vue
du prochain PLFSS rapports qui fournit
plusieurs pistes de réflexion
intéressantes notre combat je le dis
très fort n'est pas contre une filière
absolument pas et je vous rejoins dans
le soutien à voir pour nos viticulteurs
et nos brasseurs j'ai eu l'occasion de
me rendre comme vous l'avez dit
récemment dans votre belle
circonscription
par contre autre combat il est contre la
consommation excessive d'alcool notre
approche elle se base sur la prévention
sur la modération c'est avant tout un
enjeu de santé publique la consommation
excessive d'alcool et j'insiste bien sur
le terme excessive et encore responsable
dans notre pays de 41000 morts par an
nous avons ainsi une action générale de
prévention je pense aux campagnes de
communication régulière notamment ciblée
vers des jeunes et vers les milieux
festifs avec le programme ami aussi la
nuit je pense aussi à ce que nous
déployons autour de l'allée vers pour
identifier accompagner d'un point de vue
psychologique les victimes car ce sont
des victimes de ces addictions et vous
l'avez dit on observe des résultats
positifs sur la consommation d'alcool
mensuel qui a reculé de 13 points en 10
ans chez les jeunes de 17 ans par
exemple en outre comme chaque année le
PLFSS sera l'occasion d'un débat sur
notre niveau de prélèvement sur certains
produits dont les produits à base
d'alcool et je pense essentiellement aux
alcools forts cette réflexion associera
bien entendu l'ensemble des parties
prenantes bien évidemment les
parlementaires de la majorité comme de
l'opposition comme j'ai déjà commencé à
le faire nous aurons ainsi à la rentrée
des consultations larges sur le PLFSS a
du Ken et avec mon collègue Gabriel
Attal je vous remercie merci beaucoup
coucou monsieur ministre la parole est à
Monsieur Pierre Morel à l'huissier pour
le coupliath
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le garde
des sceaux
ma chérie dans quelques jours cela fera
10 ans qu'un fou du volant t'a pris ta
vie à briser la nôtre celle de ton petit
frère et celle de tous ceux qui t'aiment
et qui ne t'oublie pas disons que je me
bats pour qu'enfin sont reconnus l'homme
ici de routier disons que le député de
la Lozère nous soutient dans ce combat
alors aujourd'hui je pense à toi Mallory
et à toutes ces victimes innocentes de
chauffeur de la route je pense à tous
ces parents qui souffrent et à tous nos
amis réunis au congrès de Moulins on ne
lâchera rien maman des témoignages comme
celui-ci chaque député peut en recevoir
on ne peut rester insensible de telles
situations qui provoque le décès d'un
proche d'un père d'une mère d'un enfant
ou des blessures qui impactent toute
l'une de vie tout au long d'une vie
humaine à cause d'un comportement
routier irresponsable nous sommes
plusieurs parlementaires de tout bord
politique à nous être emparés de ce
sujet en lien avec plusieurs
associations victime aussi monsieur le
ministre je vous donne de permettre un
débat parlementaire le plus ouvert qui
soit allant parfois au-delà des mesures
annoncées afin de présenter et voter un
texte consensuel et adopté aux réalités
humaines que je viens de rappeler
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à monsieur Éric du
pontre de la justice
merci madame la présidente madame
monsieur le députés monsieur le député
Morel à l'huissier vous appelez de vos
vœux un débat parlementaire vous l'aurez
c'est une certitude vous êtes
effectivement plusieurs à être engagés
sur ce sujet de longue date madame
bonniera jolie dit vous-même d'autre
parlementaires monsieur Poget bien sûr
que je ne peux pas oublier hier ma
première ministre a annoncé que nous
allions donner à cette terrible
infraction le nom qui est le bon et nous
allons créer une infraction autonome
mais il y a d'autres mesures donc je
veux rapidement vous vous parler que je
porte avec Gérald Darmanin le ministre
de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer d'abord
la contravention de grande excès de
vitesse va devenir un délit
rappelons que c'est 41 000
excès de grandes vitesses en 2019
72000 en 2022 la création d'un délit de
désignation frauduleuse du conducteur
fictif d'un véhicule en infraction
l'assimilation à la conduite sans permis
au regard de la récidive des infractions
liées aux restrictions du droit de
conduire pour mieux appréhender la
récidive la possibilité pour le
procureur de la République de confisquer
un permis pendant 12 mois au lieu de 6
et la possibilité pour le tribunal
judiciaire de confisquer je dis bien de
confisquer un véhicule vous savez ma
détermination à lutter contre les
comportements routiers les plus
dangereux sans attendre ces évolutions
législatives auxquelles nous nous
associerons bien sûr avec vous je
voudrais vous dire que je prends dans
les prochains jours une circulaire de
politique pénale en matière routière
dans la droite ligne du comité
interministériel je souhaite que l'on
prenne en compte les victimes mieux que
nous le faisons et en particulier
s'agissant de l'information qu'il aurait
dû du suivi bien sûr je souhaite
rappeler dans cette circulaire que les
victimes ont des droits que ces droits
méritent bien sûr d'être respectés je le
dis monsieur le député amplifié merci
beaucoup monsieur Morel huissier
monsieur le ministre merci pour le débat
je sais je connais votre sensibilité et
je ne doute pas que nous ferons œuvril
merci beaucoup je vous remercie mon cher
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
Sébastien Petavy pour le couple
écologique
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues encore aujourd'hui
le gouvernement fait peser sur les
épaules des plus précaires le poids de
son incapacité à prévoir les crises
futures face à ces 10% d'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie annoncée seulement
4% d'augmentation du SMIC les pensions
0,8%. le point d'indice des
fonctionnaires
1,5%, qui supporte l'inflation la
réforme des retraites l'effondrement de
notre système de soins ce sont les plus
précaires ce sont ceux à qui vous
demandez encore aujourd'hui injustement
des efforts or gouverner c'est anticipé
nous avions déjà alerté lors de la mise
en place du bouclier tarifaire que cette
solution d'urgence n'était ni juste ni
pérenne car certes crise qui est loin de
se terminer n'est ni la première ni la
dernière et les Français n'ont pas à
payer de votre manque d'investissement
dans les énergies renouvelables et dans
l'efficacité énergétique le Grenelle de
l'environnement fixait l'objectif de 38%
de baisse des consommations dans le
bâtiment pour 2020 nous lançons
aujourd'hui qu'à 1%. le résultat
aujourd'hui c'est une augmentation de
150 euros par an qui va obliger les
familles les plus modestes à faire des
arbitrages entre manger offrir des
vacances et leurs enfants ou payer les
factures d'électricité vous souhaitez
faire 14 milliards d'euros d'économistes
au lieu de pénaliser les plus pauvres
vous auriez pu choisir d'exclure du
bouclier tarifaire les 20% les plus
riches qui sont ceux qui consomment le
plus vous auriez ainsi dégagé cinq à six
milliards d'euros d'économies tout en
encourageant la sobriété énergétique
vous auriez aussi pu choisir dans un
monde réellement apaisé de mettre en
place un bouclier tarifaire juste avec
des tarifs progressifs sur l'énergie
pour garantir les premiers qu'il est
watts heure pour les besoins vitaux se
laver s'alimenter se chauffer et faire
ainsi payer plus cher l'énergie dite
superflu alors madame la ministre quelle
option avez-vous donc à nous offrir pour
une énergie accessible durable et
résiliente face aux crises présentes et
à venir
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Agnès panière une
hachée ministre la transition
énergétique merci madame la Présidente
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député pétavie vous vous inquiétez du
noce de 10 % des coûts de l'électricité
mais monsieur le député dois-je vous
rappeler que c'est vous et votre groupe
qui n'avait pas voté le bouclier
énergétique qui a permis de limiter
massivement la hausse des prix
d'électricité pour les français pour les
collectivités territoriales et pour les
et pour les entreprises dois-je
également vous rappeler puisque vous
formulez votre inquiétude par rapport au
développement des énergies renouvelables
que c'est vous et votre groupe qui
n'avait pas voté la loi d'accélération
des énergies renouvelables et dois-je
également vous rappeler que c'est vous
et votre groupe qui n'avait pas voté la
loi d'accélération de l'énergie
nucléaire parce que comme vous le savez
il faudra à la fois du nucléaire et des
énergies renouvelables pour permettre à
notre pays d'avoir en une énergie
abondante pas chère produite sur notre
territoire au bénéfice des industries et
qui permettent de créer de l'emploi car
c'est très exactement la politique que
nous menons à la stratégie que nous que
nous avons dois-je également vous
rappeler monsieur le député que nous
n'avons pas entendu beaucoup de soutien
sur le plan sobriété ce plan sobriété
qui a permis à l'ensemble des grandes
entreprises l'ensemble des grandes
administrations l'ensemble des grandes
collectivités locales de réduire leur
consommation d'énergie et qui nous a
permis de baisser nos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre de 2,7% l'année dernière
au premier trimestre de 4%. alors
Monsieur le Député quand vous mettrez en
cohérence vos actes et vos paroles et
votre vos amendements et vos votes au
début à l'Assemblée nationale on pourra
continuer à discuter vous avez une
plateforme c'est la loi de programmation
énergie que climat je vous attends sur
ce point je vous remercie madame la
ministre
la parole est à monsieur Thibault
François pour le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les échanges de SMS avec le PDG de
Pfizer lors de la négociation des juteux
contrats de vaccins par exemple nombre
de gouvernements ont pourtant dénoncé
ces dérives de la commission qui fait
trop souvent fille de la volonté des
peuples européens et de leurs intérêts
comme le démontre cette nomination se
mépris envers les États membres à peine
caché dans les propos de la porte-parole
de la Commission Dana spinner je cite la
décision a été prise nous ne voyons pas
de pas de raison de la reconsidérer cela
doit cesser il n'existe de supériorités
des bureaucrates de la Commission
européenne sur la volonté des peuples
européens madame la Première ministre
allez vous réellement vous opposer à
cette nomination ou bien les vous
continuer à laisser la Commission
européenne dictée ses règles envers et
contre tous les États membres je vous
remercie je vous remercie la
parole est Ministre chargée extérieur de
l'attractivité des Français de
l'étranger
si beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
mesdames monsieur le député Thibault
François
je voudrais associer à ma réponse le
ministre délégué Jean-Noël Barrault et
vous dire que j'ai déjà répondu au
député la tombe sur ce sujet néanmoins
je voudrais redire la position du
gouvernement oui ce profil pose question
tant sur la question des conflits
d'intérêts que sur celle de la
souveraineté européenne vous avez raison
sur la souveraineté européenne et je
veux redire concernant cette domination
qu'il s'agit d'un processus certes
interne à la Commission européenne mais
dont nous demandons leur examen de la
décision nous l'avons expressément
invité à le faire je note aussi c'est
très clair je note aussi je note aussi
que le Parlement européen se saisit de
la question et auditionne aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui même la commissaire veste à
guerre et pourquoi pourquoi le Parlement
européen fait cela parce que l'idée de
souveraineté européenne portée par le
Président de la République et poussé par
la France depuis six ans et désormais
majoritaire en Europe la défense oui la
défense des intérêts stratégiques de
l'Union européenne de nos entreprises et
de nos emplois et désormais une boussole
de notre action au niveau européen
partagez à la fois par les États membres
et les institutions européennes et ce
succès c'est aussi au président et à
cette majorité que nous le devons nous
attendons aujourd'hui que la Commission
européenne suive cette voix et réexamine
la décision de nomination de Madame
fioda Scott Morton je vous remercie je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre
monsieur le député je vous remercie en
effet monsieur le ministre depuis trop
longtemps vous attendez la Commission
européenne qui je le rappelle ne
représente personne alors que les
pouvoirs devraient être au Conseil
européen qui lui représentent les
peuples alors vous venez dire que vous
avez une majorité au Parlement européen
et dans l'Union européenne je vous
rappelle que vous aviez perdu les
élections en 2019 et je vous prédis que
vous allez d'ailleurs perdre les
prochaines élections que Jordan Bardella
va gagner en 2024 alors rendez-vous en
juin
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Mohamed là qu'il a pour le
groupe démocrate merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics monsieur Gabriel Attal
nous une nouvelle phase de notre gestion
des finances publiques je tiens tout
d'abord à saluer votre initiative
renouvelée cette année encore avec les
dialogues de Bercy qui inclut toutes les
sensibilités parlementaires après le
quoiqu'il en coûte qui a permis de
préserver des centaines de milliers
d'entreprises et d'emplois puis les
mesures d'urgence pour répondre à
l'inflation en premier lieu le bouclier
tarifaire qui ont permis d'atténuer
l'effet de la hausse des prix sur le
pouvoir d'achat de nos concitoyens nous
devons désormais accélérer sur la
rationalisation des dépenses publiques
et le désendettement parce qu'une France
tropendettée c'est une France qui
abdique de sa souveraineté et abandonne
son avenir
vous avez présenté en fin de semaine un
document sur les plafonds des dépenses
de l'État pour 2024 avec des économies
principalement sur la fin des mesures
d'urgence nous le saluons
mais c'est seul efforts ne suffiront
hélas pas à rétablir durablement nos
finances publiques un outil essentiel et
la lutte contre la fraude contre toutes
les fraudes c'est nécessaire pour
garantir la justice sociale et en la
matière nous n'avons pas rugir de nos
efforts à ce titre nous travaillons
depuis des mois avec vous monsieur le
ministre sur la fraude à la TVA première
recette pour son montant et donc
première source potentielle de fraude
par des outils simples nous voulons y
répondre efficacement avec un effet avec
un fort effet de levier potentiel et
donc des perspectives de financement
pour nos enjeux d'aujourd'hui et de
demain
entre autres l'adaptation au changement
climatique la santé de nos concitoyens
et l'accompagnement de chacun vers un
logement digne et durable pouvez-vous
monsieur le ministre nous préciser où en
est la phase de lancement de la facture
électronique nos entreprises qu'elles
soient grandes ou petites nos
administrations sont-elles prêtes à
faire face à cette nouvelle obligation
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Gabriel Attal ministre chargé
des comptes publics
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Mohammed lakila d'abord je vous remercie
d'avoir mentionné les dialogues de Bercy
effectivement j'ai souhaité relancer
cette initiative cette année je crois
profondément au dialogue par de là les
clivages politiques et je ne sais pas ce
qu'il adviendra du vote des uns et des
autres sur le projet de loi de finances
même si j'entends que les oppositions
estiment qu'il s'agit d'une appartenance
ou non à la majorité mais en tout cas je
pense que ce sera utile au pays qu'on
soit capable d'y travailler tous
ensemble en amont et qu'il n'y a que du
positif qui peut ressortir d'un dialogue
de l'ensemble des forces politiques pour
le budget de notre pays vous abordez la
question de la lutte contre la fraude et
la lutte contre la fraude sera un
chapitre majeur du projet de loi de
finances de même qu'il sera un chapitre
majeur du projet de loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale quand on parle de
fraude fiscale la fraude fiscale pour
laquelle nous avons une évaluation la
plus solide c'est la fraude à la TVA
estimée par l'Insee et la DG FIP à 20
milliards d'euros par an on en recouvre
quelques milliards aujourd'hui donc on
voit qu'on doit être beaucoup plus
efficace sur ce sujet là dès le prochain
PLF il y aura un certain nombre de
mesures sur le sujet notamment je
souhaite qu'il y ait dans le prochain
aplf une mesure s'agissant du
dropshipping vous savez la vente sur
Internet dans laquelle le vendeur ne se
charge que de la commercialisation et de
la vente de produits c'est une pratique
qui s'est particulièrement développée
ces dernières années et qui se prête
particulièrement à des schémas
d'évitement de la TVA il y aura donc une
mesure pour réformer les règles de la
TVA à l'importation deuxième sujet vous
avez beaucoup travaillé sur ce sujet là
les relations entre assujettis vous avez
fait beaucoup de propositions sur ce
sujet je souhaite qu'on avance dans le
cadre du PLF avec ce que la directive
TVA nous permet de faire enfin vous
l'avez dit le chantier majeur c'est la
faction électronique inter-entreprise
elle a été adoptée par ce Parlement elle
doit se mettre en vigueur
progressivement à l'horizon 2026 pour sa
pleine entrée en vigueur je vous dis mon
objectif c'est qu'elle rentre en vigueur
et qu'elle soit soutenable pour les
entreprises qui sont les premières
concernées nous allons continuer à
travailler avec elle à ce que le
calendrier permette à cette réforme
d'être soutenable je vous remercie merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la parole
est à Monsieur Steve Chaillot pour le
groupe PDR
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres chers collègues
ma question s'adresse au ministre des
Armées monsieur le ministre j'attire
votre attention sur la situation de
détresse des blessés de guerre en
Polynésie pour préserver ses intérêts
dans le monde la France a été contraint
de les jeter dans la bataille et de ce
fait ils ont comme le disait Clémenceau
des droits sur nous tous notamment celui
de juillet d'un accompagnement dans
toutes les démarches administratives
juridiques ou encore social depuis la
constatation de leur blessure jusqu'à
leur retour à l'emploi ce soutien est
nécessaire pour compenser la perte
d'autonomie que provoque leur blessure
il s'agit là d'une contrepartie évidente
au sacrifice qu'ils ont consenti pour la
nation or en Polynésie une telle
contrepartie s'avère défaillante ce sont
les cellules des trois armées qui ont
pour mission d'assurer un tel suivi mais
lorsque ces derniers sortent de
l'hexagone et regagne typiquement la
Polynésie leur situation semble échapper
à la compétence d'édit de cellules
l'éloignement géographique du fait nous
impôts principal cause les cellules
d'aide ne connaissent en Polynésie aucun
équivalent en terme de moyens lorsque le
militaire blessé et radié des contrôles
de l'armée s'est défendent
jusqu'au retour à l'emploi le pôle
Défense Mobilité en Polynésie souffre
d'une insuffisance défectif et d'un fort
taux de roulement qui ne permet pas le
suivi complet et constant des blessés de
guerre en Polynésie leur accompagnement
et lacunaire et se sont donc les blessés
eux-mêmes qui finissent par en sort en
souffrir alors que la Polynésie offre
chaque année à la France près de 600 de
ses enfants
pour alimenter l'armée une telle
souffrance est inacceptable ma question
est donc simple monsieur le ministre
quelle action l'État français quand ils
mettent en place pour résoudre cette
situation ma Loulou Thierry merci
beaucoup monsieur le député la parole
est à Madame Sarah elle a écrit ministre
en charge de la jeunesse et du service
national universel
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
Mesdames Messieurs les Députés monsieur
le député Chaillou je voulais d'abord
présenter les excuses du ministre des
armées qui actuellement à l'étranger et
qui m'a fait part de la réponse qui lui
tenait extrêmement à coeur monsieur le
député vous avez raison des droits des
droits sur nous tous pour leur sacrifice
oui bien sûr évidemment pour l'ensemble
de nos blessés quel que soit en réalité
leur territoire mais il y a des
spécificités dans nos autres mères c'est
une réalité vous évoquez plusieurs
points je pense évidemment à
l'accompagnement physique mais également
à l'éloignement à posteriori du retour
en tout cas de l'Hexagone ce qui est
certain c'est que tous les aspects du
parcours doivent être garantis et le
premier d'entre eux c'est l'accès aux
droits et on sait à quel point cet accès
au droit et bien a besoin en réalité du
plan blessé qui a été annoncé par ma
collègue Patricia mirales le dit mai
dernier renforcé également par les
propos du président de la République à
l'Hôtel de Brienne le 13 juillet dernier
Monsieur le député s'est accompagnement
c'est un c'est un du nous leur devons
nous leur devons avec leur famille le
premier axe de ce plan et il va à toute
vitesse c'est d'abord faciliter cet
accès le présent de la République a
aussi rappelé que plus que jamais la
pension militaire d'invalidité doit être
facilité elle sera automatisée et rendue
en réalité en format numérique pour
faciliter son ex ce sera effectivement
là bientôt c'est imminant pour les
blessures psychiques et on sait à quel
point elles sont importantes la
télé-expertise va être favorisée
également grâce à un décret pour éviter
les déplacements non essentiels et on
sait que ça coûte en réalité à nos
blessés en matière d'accompagnement les
cellules d'aide que vous connaissez bien
sûr vont être densifiés un meilleur
accompagnement en fonction de la réalité
du tissu local étant travail plus que
jamais on investissement financier et
essentiel 16 millions d'Euros pour
renforcer également ces cellules parce
que c'est d'abord l'humain qui qui
accompagne avec un effort particulier
sur les outre-mer 6 au moins seront à
destination il y a également les maisons
Atos que vous connaissez une à deux
nouvelle seront seront développées pour
les outre-mer puisqu'on sait que ça a
fait ses preuves c'est des accomp
agnements très spécifiques et Monsieur
le Député vous pouvez compter sur la
mobilisation de l'ensemble de la maison
des armées pour accompagner nos blessés
mais en réalité surtout le gouvernement
je vous remercie madame la ministre la
parole est à monsieur Adrien cadenas sur
le groupe la France insoumise
madame la Première ministre
ceux qui ont pris tout le plat dans leur
assiette laissant les assiettes des
autres vides et qui ayant tout dit avec
une bonne figure une bonne conscience
nous nous qui avons tout on est pour la
paix les premiers provocateurs c'est
vous ces mots madame la Première
ministre sont de l'abbé Pierre et à coup
sûr ils auraient suffit à ce que vous
l'excluez de votre arc républicain mais
où se cache la République dans votre arc
républicain je vous le demande car où
est la République quand une petite
poignée s'accapare tout et que pour tant
d'autres il ne reste rien la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme de 1789 affirme
que l'impôt est également répartie entre
les citoyens en fonction de leur faculté
pour la quasi-totalité de la population
le système fiscal est progressif mais à
partir des 0,1% les plus riches il
devient régressif
plutôt d'impôts sur le revenu des
milliardaires et proche de zéro et une
telle accumulation ne peut se faire que
sur le dos des autres alors madame la
Première ministre du prétendu arc
républicain je vous le demande où est la
République quand l'essence sont plus
grandes fortunes s'accaparent près de la
moitié des richesses produites pendant
qu'un Français sur trois ne disposent
plus que de 100 euros sur son compte
bancaire dès le 10 du mois et 15 sur
deux saute un repas où est la République
quand les réformes fiscales de votre
gouvernement bénéficie quatre fois plus
aux 10% les plus riches Kodi pour cent
les plus pauvres où est la République
quand le plus fortuné gagne en 24 heures
ce qu'un salarié au Smic ne parviendra
pas à gagner en toute une vie où est la
République sans l'égalité où est la
République sans la justice sociale
je vous remercie la parole est à me fait
Gabriel Attal ministre délégué chargé
des comptes publics
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
vous pouvez tordre les choses dans tous
les sens que vous le souhaitez et tordre
les chiffres dans tous les sens que vous
le souhaitez vous n'arriverez pas à
faire croire qu'un pays qui est le
deuxième pays des 38 pays de l'OCDE en
matière de prélèvement obligatoire est
un paradis fiscal vous n'arriverez pas à
faire croire qu'un pays qui est le
dernier pays de l'Union européenne à
avoir un impôt national sur la fortune
est un paradis fiscal vous n'arriverez
pas à faire croire qu'un pays ou 10% des
contribuables paye 75% de l'impôt sur le
revenu est un paradis fiscal vous
n'arriverez pas à faire croire qu'un
pays où le taux marginal d'imposition
quand on y ajoute la contribution
exceptionnelle sur les hauts revenus et
de 49% il n'y a pas de comparable dans
l'Union européenne et un paradis fiscal
la réalité c'est que la France n'est un
paradis fiscal pour personne vous citer
vous citez nos réformes fiscales et
notamment le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
vous citez nos réformes fiscales et
notamment le prélèvement forfaitaire
unique
mais si la France est un paradis fiscal
ça veut dire que l'Espagne vos amis de
podemos sont au pouvoir c'est un super
paradis fiscal ils ont plus d'impôt sur
la fortune et ils taxe moins les
dividendes que nous ça veut dire que
l'Allemagne ou les sociaux-démocrates
sont au gouvernement c'est un super
paradis fiscal qui taxe moins les
dividendes que nous après la réforme que
nous avons réalisé on continue à taxer
plus que nos voisins européens la
réalité c'est que la France n'est un
paradis fiscal pour personne mais que
vous voulez en faire un enfer fiscal
pour tout le monde on a vu les
amendements que vous avez déposés au
moment du PLF vous voulez taxer les
ouvriers qui font des heures
supplémentaires vous voulez taxer les
patrons de PME qui recrutent des
salariés au SMIC vous avez même proposé
de taxer les successions dès le premier
euro alors même que 80% des successions
sont exonérées de droits de succession
dans notre pays c'est ça la vraie
différence entre vous et nous vous
voulez taxer tout ce qui bouge même si à
la fin ça bouge ailleurs dans un autre
pays ça ne vous pose pas de problème
nous on souhaite que la richesse soit
créée en France et qu'elle bénéficie à
tous les Français c'est ce sur quoi nous
sommes en gagés je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à madame Béatrice rouleau
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Agriculture
et de la souveraineté alimentaire c'est
bien tout la fin des travaux
parlementaires et depuis le 1er juillet
le départ en vacances pour beaucoup de
Français cette période heureuse se
heurte pourtant au mur bien triste de la
réalité des abandons allant de paires
avec les départs en vacances chaque été
c'est près de 60 000 animaux délaissés
pour cause de congés
chaque année c'est plus de 100 000
animaux domestiques abandonnés par ceux
qui les ont voulu soit près de 12 par
heure
et cette année 2023 sera pire encore car
les foyers comme les refuges subissent
de plein fouet la hausse vertigineuse de
l'inflation et de l'énergie la France
détient le record européen des abandons
les refuges débordent il faut agir ils
sont essentiellement privés car ils
n'existe aucun refuge public dans bien
des départements et notamment le mien en
Seine-et-Marne la Fondation 30 Millions
d'Amis indique que ces structures sont
saturées et qu'elles subissent une
hausse drastique de leurs dépenses 13%
pour l'alimentation 15% pour
l'électricité qui va encore augmenter et
20% pour l'eau sans parler du prix des
croquettes qui a fait un bon
inimaginable la fondation en appel à la
générosité des Français qui ont déjà
bien du mal à boucler leur fin de mois
certains même ont dû se séparer de leur
compagnon en quatre pattes les donateurs
ne peuvent plus supporter seul la charge
des refuges alors Monsieur le Ministre
malgré les efforts déjà fait sous les
gouvernements Macron pour prévenir
l'acte d'abandon comme l'interdiction
un animalerie seriez-vous prêt
maintenant à créer des refuges publics
ou
assuventionner davantage les
associations je vous remercie je vous
remercie la parole est à Marc
phénoministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députés rouleau vous
avez raison de poser cette question en
particulier dans cette période estivale
parce que c'est la période qui
malheureusement rencontre le plus dans
le Bandon de chiens et de chats en tout
cas d'animaux de compagnie globalement
j'aurais rappelé parce que c'est la
volonté du gouvernement vous l'avez
souligné avec grande honnêteté c'est la
volonté du gouvernement c'est la volonté
qui est partagée sur la tringle immense
majorité de ces banques de lutter contre
l'abandon un animal n'est pas un objet
un animal n'est pas un jouet et donc ça
ne peut pas procéder d'un coup de tête
dans un magasin quand c'était encore
possible ou ailleurs c'est travail que
nous avons fait je répondrai sur votre
question pour les refuges je travaille
que nous avons fait au travers d'une loi
votée en novembre 2021 qui a permis
d'une part de vrai sur les sanctions on
a renforcé très puissamment les
sanctions en termes d'amende et au terme
de prison les sanctions sont aggravées
en cas de mort de l'animal deuxième
élément on a besoin de vrais sans
relâche sur la sensibilisation et
l'information de ceux qui souhaitent
acquérir ou adopter un animal c'est ce
que nous faisons par des campagnes de
communication estivale ça permet de
mettre tout le monde en vigilance et de
regarder les attitudes aussi des uns et
des autres de mettre chacun devant ses
responsabilités le deuxième élément
évidemment c'est de faire en sorte que
par l'acte d'acquisition on soit
sensibilisé c'est le sens du certificat
troisième élément je voudrais les saluer
comme vous l'avez fait c'est l'ensemble
des associations qui pour l'essentiel
porte les refuges comme vous le savez le
gouvernement accompagné l'enterrement
dans le cadre de France relance ça
continue d'ailleurs à se déployer parce
qu'on est en train de terminer les
crédits la consommation des crédits on a
accompagné puissamment c'est plus de 35
millions d'euros qui ont été mis sur la
table pour accompagner la modernisation
des refuges parce que comme vous le
dites les besoins en surface sont plus
importants et nous continuons j'ai
rencontré un certain nombre
d'associations mais services aussi nous
continuons à regarder comment on peut
les accompagner à la fois en
investissement
et puis deuxièmement les charges de
fonctionnement qui sont les l'air qui
sont peut-être espérons le conjoncturel
mais qui sont des charges importantes
donc comme vous le voyez on est à la
fois sur des dispositions législatives
on a déjà accompagné les refuges je
crois que le gouvernement a été au
rendez-vous et on est en train de
regarder sur d'autres besoins
d'investissement ou des besoins de
fonctionnement ce qui peut être couvert
c'est le dialogue qu'on a ouvert avec
eux pour être en lucidité capable de
répondre malheureusement à l'abandon
mais il faut d'abord essayer aussi
lutter contre la bande je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre madame boulot oui
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
donc je crois entendre en filigrane que
vous allez procéder à des augmentations
de subventions et en tout cas moi je
prépare une proposition de loi sur le
sujet et si vous voilà et je me tiens à
votre disposition merci beaucoup madame
la députée la parole est à Madame Stella
Dupont pour le groupe Renaissance
merci merci madame la Présidente ma
question s'adresse à Jean-Christophe
combe ministre des Solidarités de
l'autonomie et des personnes handicapées
monsieur le ministre en France le taux
de non recours à certaines prestations
sociales
dépasse 30 %. nous savons que ce non
recours accroît la précarité et
l'isolement des personnes concernées
mais aussi les empêche d'en sortir
lutter contre le non recours et donc un
axe stratégique de la lutte contre la
peau pauvreté ainsi l'amendement de ma
collègue Christine le nabourg lors de
l'examen de la loi 3DS instaure une
expérimentation de territoire zéro non
recours au droit pendant trois ans
depuis un appel à projet a été lancé et
39 territoires ont été sélectionnés
début juillet pour participer à cette
expérimentation et je me réjouis
d'ailleurs que Chemillé en Anjou dans ma
circonscription en Maine-et-Loire était
retenues cette démarche illustre
l'engagement de notre territoire pour un
meilleur accès au droit
l'expérimentation
permettra de lancer des initiatives de
lutte contre le non recours au droit
sociaux en développant l'information sur
les droits en étendant la démarche
d'aller vers et en mobilisant les
acteurs concernés comme les associations
les bailleurs sociaux l'État les
collectivités locales l'enjeu sera alors
d'identifier puis d'accompagner les
personnes pour qu'elles bénéficie de
100% de leurs droits RSA prime
d'activité mais aussi chaque énergie
appelle ainsi que l'accès aux services
publics cette expérimentation s'inscrit
dans le Pacte des solidarités et
poursuit la logique d'un renforcement de
l'accompagnement social des plus
fragiles il en sera aussi question lors
de l'examen de France travail qui
mettent également l'accent sur les
devoirs on aura donc l'occasion
d'évoquer les moyens à consacrer à cet
accompagnement lors des débats
budgétaires pour l'heure monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous préciser quel
sera le soutien de l'État pour les
territoires sélectionnés dans cette
expérimentation zéro non recours au
droit durant ces trois prochaines années
je vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Christophe con ministre
des Solidarités de l'autonomie des
personnes handicapées merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés mesdames la députée Stella
Dupont merci pour votre question qui me
permet de revenir sur un dispositif
précieux qui a été prévu dans le cadre
de la loi 3DS et auquel vous aviez été
nombreux à contribuer et je salue
particulièrement à ce titre votre
collègue Christine Le Nabour à laquelle
vous avez fait référence avec
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
neurocourt ou TZ Denner nous sommes en
plein cœur de la démarche en faveur de
l'accès aux droits que porte cette
majorité depuis maintenant plusieurs
années il contribue également par
exemple les maisons France service qui
ont permis de proposer une offre énergie
de services au public au plus près des
besoins des personnes sur tout le
territoire ou encore la réforme en cours
de la solidarité à la source le 6
juillet je vous l'avais dit j'ai eu le
plaisir de présenter une liste non pas
de 10 comme c'était prévu initialement
mais de 39 candidature retenue sur 67
dossiers soumis ces chiffres témoignent
de l'envie de faire d'un très grand
nombre d'acteurs locaux prêt à se
mobiliser aux côtés du gouvernement pour
l'accès à chacun de chacun au juste
droit je me réjouis bien sûr que de
Rennes à la Communauté d'Agglomération
du Pays ajaxien de Saint-Louis et
Sainte-Rose à la Réunion à Lille une
telle diversité de territoire soit
représentée dans cette expérimentation
il faut maintenant que le dispositif se
déploie rapidement car les conséquences
sociales du non-recourt sont encore bien
là en particulier pour les 30% de
Français qui ne font pas les démarches
pour avoir accès aux droits auxquels ils
peuvent prétendre les territoires seront
soutenus par l'État à hauteur de 80% des
montants engagés pendant trois ans il
bénéficieront par ailleurs d'une
animation nationale qui permettra aux
acteurs engagés des collectivités aux
associations en passant par les caisses
de sécurité sociale ou encore les
bailleurs sociaux de partager leurs
bonnes pratiques et de comparer leurs
résultats avec l'ensemble des acteurs
participants au comité de coordination
pour l'accès aux droits ne seront
particulièrement attentifs aux effets de
ces démarches qui seront bien sûr
évaluées par un comité dédié présidé par
Nicolas Duvoux le nouveau président du
Conseil national des politiques de lutte
contre la pauvreté merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre la séance des
questions au Gouvernement est terminée
la séance est suspendue pour 15 minutes
et nous reprendrons sur le vote
solennelle des projets de la justice